well good afternoon everyone and welcome
to uh
our meeting um for december um
firstly uh and welcome to um
those who are presenting today and and
uh and our guests it's great to have you
here with us uh so firstly i'll just
call for apologies
kirsten um i have to leave at 5 15 today
mr man
okay
hopefully we still have some members
here by the time we've got some business
to discuss
wendy
okay all right all right
welcome all right so uh any conflicts of
interest oh sorry firstly i'll move that
those apologies
at those noted times be accepted
moved by councillor atkinson seconded by
council meetings
i put those all those in favor aye
contrary to clear that carriage uh any
conflicts of interest that members wish
to declare
9.1 thanks mr winner nation thank you
council brian all right at this point um
i'm just going to adjourn our uh meeting
briefly
so we can undertake a presentation of a
community service awards just while we
get ourselves in
place or just during the meeting and
we were thinking of doing it up at the
front but
we'll see how we go you can do it down
the back here okay i think
it might make it easier
let's get the jewellery on
glenn scott glen has been a dedicated
volunteer at the northern bulldogs rugby
league club for many years
over those years glenn has spent
countless hours irrigating and
maintaining
the playing fields at murphy park all
visitors to the park benefit from grant
glenn's work
not just the league club he irrigates
the grounds all summer
so the park is always in pristine
condition and is a wonderful space
for people walking their dogs and having
picnics or fishing
glen is a very generous sponsor and has
brought a strong group of sponsors
on the board to support the bulldogs
club
without his his sponsorship it would be
an annual struggle
to pay for uniforms training gear as
well as
for insurance in the upkeep of the club
rooms
the couple club rooms were completely
destroyed in the earthquakes
and uninsured but glenn was instrumental
in their rebuild
he rallied architects to engineers
builders sponsors
and helpers and met council that went
countless times with council to ensure
the rebuild
build could be realized in a
cost-effective and timely manner
long-time club members are adamant that
glenn's dedication and hard work were
instrumental
in the project being brought to
completion and to reality
as as part of the rebuild glean was
actively involved in organizing
the build of a spec home in sovereign
palms
the build was the the home was auctioned
and profit went straight
into the rebuild of the club rooms the
bulldogs committee
and members passed in prison were in no
doubt
that glenn contributed a substantial
amount amount of his personal finances
to the rebuild of the club rooms under
the radar
he did it simply because he knew how
important it was for the community
that the club rooms were reinstated
glenn is a tireless
player scout for the bulldogs he employs
many of the players
at his family-run business in caipore
and takes personal interest in them and
their families
this supportive culture that glenn
promotes has obvious benefits with both
senior teams making the grand finals
this year
for the years glenn was club for years
glenn was club president
he ensured that local businesses were
used in the day-to-day running of the
club
from misco joinery mike greer homes
north canterbury
kuiper itn phoenix pharmacy larsen signs
rock gas and physio south to the local
carpet layer
who fitted out the club rooms glenn is a
fantastic supporter of local business
as an avid bulldog supporter glenn has
been involved in the club
from a very young age he has been
president committee member
player coach spent countless hours
running the club
club rooms and has unselfishly donated
time
money and whatever resources he can
whenever asked
he also found time to coach canterbury
age group
teams green gleamers
has the utmost respect of players senior
club members
and sponsors supporters and committee
he is a very he is very deserving of
recognition of a
community service award for his vast
contribution to the northern bulldogs
rugby league club
and the wider kaiboy community
the first item we'll come to is the
confirmation
of minutes that pages 12 to 36 of the
agenda
someone prepared to move that there are
true incorrect recall counselor redmond
seconded by council of duty i thought i
saw your hand move
yeah excellent moving the recommendation
i'll
do you wish to speak no i'll
i'll put the recommendation always in
favor all right
contrary to clear that carried so we'll
come to the
4.2 and the public excluded agenda
any matters arising for the minutes
okay i just uh
we've got a couple of late item agenda
items
relating to good street and council
submission on plane change
30 so i'll move from the chair that we
resolve
to include the late agenda items on the
agenda
both and as listed good street and
council submission on plan change
30. you're happy to second that anyone
wish to speak
i'll put that all those in favor aye
contrary to clear that carriage so we
come to deputations and presentations
and we've got
uh three this afternoon um
5.1 with aleister cameron so alistair if
you could make your way to the front of
the table there
welcome following we'll have the cancer
society
and then we will then hear from knight
to hariri and just for
representatives from nigeria um i intend
to then take
report number 9.1 which relates to the
speed limit straight after that so if
you wish to stay for treasury
you can do that so you can hear the
debate right
so um alastair welcome to our meeting um
and we've received a copy of
[Music]
some written comments from you so thank
you for providing those
members of you you'll find that in your
um
in the diligence system there so
alistair
um up to 10 minutes with the opportunity
for some questions and we look forward
to hearing from you
thank you
um good afternoon uh
there it councils started perhaps we
could just move the microphone a bit
closer it's just a bit hard to hear
thank you good afternoon
mayor councillors and staff thank you
for
giving me the time
i've put a submission in that's
primarily about
development contributions of my
subdivision and
unsure would you want me to read it or
well we're in your hands so if you'd
like to read it that's fine if you want
to summarise that just assume that
colleagues have read the
submission but you're welcome to read it
um totally in your hands alistair
whatever you'd prefer
i'll just i'll just start with the
summary of sure
i seek remissions for part of the
development contributions
levied by the council on my subdivision
at graveyard grove
i believe the remission is justified
giving the costs and delays that have
endured during the process of obtaining
a resource concern
due and large uh due in large part to
issues and delays caused or exacerbated
by council requests requirements and
decisions
i've not included the precise number for
the remission of ask council staff
previously for comparative figures
could have only received an initial
figure which contained errors
and a revised full figure at the full
post 2016 rate
what i seek is the council determine
what would be a fair emission
and the circumstances with any necessary
input from council officers
so the introduction of subdivided a
2.2 hectare site which was formerly 90
east belt ring or
now known as graveyard grove the process
to develop the subdivision from
conception
and consenting to practical completion
took from
early 2007 until
october 2016
almost 10 years for this relatively
modest subdivision
i've been charged with i'll be charged
for development contributions
by the council which over the span of
this process
grew as they reassessed against changed
policies
that would have been avoided had it not
been beset with the issues of dubious
merit delays often council related
then council's requests to amend the
development
i'm therefore requesting that the
council reach a fair and reasonable
outcome in relation to the
development contributions i must pay
that is to levy the development
contributions for 25
lots of my subdivision
under the original 2011 application rate
with the additional five lots created
under the revised subdivision design
charged the subsequent 2016 rate
that outcome would go some way to
recognizing the additional costs
including additional application fees
i've had to incur
also note the following i understand it
for some
of the re i understand some of the
reason why the council
counseled me to withdraw the first
application apply for a new application
unfortunately what was not explained was
the additional cost
that would be incurred with the granting
of this new consent
and from the revised development
contribution policies
that the resultant delay meant i would
then incur
now the council is also seeking
additional amounts
over and above the calculation was
provided
due to a mistake they made in their
calculation
of the development contributions owing
this was following the new application
this situation is unreasonable in my
view
for all the reasons that follow below
during this process i had dealings with
more than 20
council staff many of them who have now
moved on
this in itself has created its own
delays and additional costs
as new staff have had to get up to speed
as of today's date i've paid the
development contributions that we're
leaving
part of that amount is being held in my
lawyer's trust account pending the
outcome for your consideration
what follows is a largely chronological
commentary of the myriad of hoops
that i've had to jump through to develop
my subdivision
the sheer number of issues i've
encountered
and which have contributed to my
council's actions or inactions in my
view justify the grounding and the
remission i seek
now there's
many pages of the basically the history
of the thing
and i don't
wish to war that but
by going to page nine
the acknowledgments acknowledgements i
wish to acknowledge that the former
mayor
and the new mayor and the lake
councillor peter ellen the chief
executive
and planning managers have been
supportive of supportive of this small
subdivision
however in my view unfortunately the
failings and problems due to the
inability of the three
water staff to resolve significant
existing stormwater issues and the
inability to consult over the sewer
connections
have resulted in avoidable delays
and costs now the development manager
gary stevenson
is insisting on the payment of
development contributions in full
without taking all these issues that not
have been mine making
into consideration and
it's i guess
what i'm saying is that i've had to do
[Music]
conclusions as a small civil contractor
with over 40 years experience i mean the
tenacity and ability to sort the
following problems
in my view caused by the council in
action or air at a huge cost to myself
the stormwater swail drain that the
council were going to install
and this is included in the attachments
this is a
letter and tooth out february 2007 from
owen davies and a design plan from 2001.
completely i've had to completely raise
the height of my subdivision due to the
unresolved stormwater issues
had to engage additional experts
hydrologists
engineering consultants to design the
stormwater swales that i had to install
which now benefit all the surrounding
properties
resolve the sewer connection issues
and so i'd just like the council really
to consider that
i've had to construct
engage panel deli moore and david sages
consultants to
construct a swale that the council were
going to
do and
the area to the north of me there's
about 21 hectares to the west and the
north of me
that pushed water out onto east belt and
just kept flowing
down through our site and i've got a 2.2
hectare site so
the three waters staff have sort of
conveniently
pushed me into a situation of having to
fund
something that's 10 times the size of my
site and i think that's just
totally unreasonable and
i'm hoping that you will take the time
of asking for a decision today i'm
hoping that you'll
take the time to read this and see some
of the background
and the difficulty that's i've had to
encounter and uh i've just
you know and even even as of
today's date basically the water i just
like to pass a few photos around
showing that we've got a mini river that
comes
basically from wales street north of the
high school
yes yes um
i've got a copy here of my neighbor's
house
the rightness with the water about to go
in their front door
and and
as i've just said that even even a
little bit of rain that we
had last yesterday afternoon and last
into early evening
the new soak pit that the councillor put
in
just north of my site is not coping so
the water is still coming at us
that conclude your points you'd like to
make alistair does that conclude the
points you'd like pretty much
so just before i call for questions from
colleagues just to perhaps just for
colleagues information and yours yeah as
to how i propose we
consider your matter going forward is
that thank you for your letter we
will call for a report to come back to
us and to be considered at a future
meeting likely as part of our long-term
plan but
at the earliest our february meetings so
just to let you know that's what
i'll be calling for of our staff to do
following um
your presentation today because it's as
you say it's a bit difficult for us to
respond at this point because we'll need
to consider that
in the context of some staff advice on
that as well but
thank you for bringing the match to our
attention council redmond
uh thank you for coming along alistair
uh we
we're sharing a microphone um
i wasn't sure from your um submission
i'm i'm assuming you've actually had
titles issued
yes correctives right i wondered how
that might have occurred when you
from what i can gather haven't paid all
the development contributions at this
point
i think it was mentioned that sitting in
a trust account yes
so set aside i paid
on stage one which was 12 lots i paid
what was in my consent
and it then the council said all of the
they've made a mistake in my consent and
the figure is actually more
so when i come to do stage two i'll put
the additional money into a solicitor's
trust account
okay right so
the council were happy to issue your
certificates
to enable they have yes whilst this
matters
to be fair jim palmer i felt was very
good about trying to receive uh get an
outcome
thank you council award
so thank you i can understand your
frustration
um going back to truth are the early
days
um did you have issues with
working in with the high school the high
school board and getting getting
consents
and getting things underway at that time
was that a hold up for you yeah it was a
hold up yes
so that prolonged it um
[Music]
that that was with
the biggest issue was the overland flow
path of stormwater coming from the north
from the high school i waited when i got
that leader in 2007 i waited for the
council i said it was going to be done
in the
0910 year that was funding allocated now
i made a start in 2011
thinking well if they're a wee bit
behind that's not going to be an issue
it'll happen
but it never happened and then i
incurred the roth of the
then school principal and it wasn't
until the commissioner
was put in uh or that
she just could she couldn't understand
what all the fuss was about
it was excellent to deal with
um that's that's good so
so you've paid for the 2005 rates in
full
um in 2006 is that correct you've paid
that do you know how much that was
sorry the first amount that you paid for
the um development
contribution nearly half a million
dollars really
yeah that was in 2007
no no no no my titles never got issued
until uh like around 2018.
all right so when did you pay is that
half a million dollars what you've paid
in total the first 12.
first 12 years but now i've since paid
another sum
so what is the sum that's in trust uh
the difference is the dif the argument i
think is on the
last the stage 2a
there's there was only two titles in
that right
and to get around that we put the
difference in what the council is asking
and what is in my consent but the
problem i had
had i've been able to carry on with my
2011 application i would have incurred
significantly lesser
fees but when i
and had i know and i would never have
withdrawn my
my first application in fact it was the
second application i wouldn't have
thought that and gone with what really
is the third application
and i and i i think that
what we're really the debate is here is
that that
i felt if i'd been charged for the first
25 lots
uh if that charged that at the 2011
now i certainly could live with that but
i'm more than happy to pay the full
development contributions on the changed
the extra five lots the council come
along
just prior to issuing my consent at 16
council come along and want to do a peer
review
and increase it to
35 watts
and they the designer
person that was the consultant for the
council come up with me building 10
two-story units in the middle of the
site and i
just couldn't handle that at all i
thought that
with carports so they would from what i
could see then was that
that perhaps investors might buy those
as rentals
and that would completely kill what i'm
trying to do is promote
standalone townhouses for the old yes as
such
i intend to live there
will we have access to um what
what the progress and the progress
payments that you've made yes
yes council but i think i don't want to
get too bogged in the detail now because
we've got a lot to get through
as i said earlier we'll call for a
report right
and it'll have all that information and
alistair we'll
make sure a copy of that report is
furnished to you
and you can provide further comment at
that time if you'd like to but
in terms of process that'll come back to
us to consider
okay right is there any further
questions
loyalist to thank you for your time and
for
uh putting through a considered
submission and we will come back to you
uh with our response all right thank you
look i've just got
two plans i'd like to pass around i can
send them down either side of the table
and leave them with you thank you which
basically shows my sight and the
balance area so thanks for your time
thank you for your time
thank you
all right uh we now come to israel 5.2
and that's
uh from i'd like to welcome the cancer
society
uh martin whitten and team um
and you're going to do it you got a
powerpoint presentation is that right
thank you so we'll just keep you guess
my name is gabriel o'connell i'm the
area coordinator for the cancer society
and we now have a hub in rangiora
and that hub services waimakiri and
kaikoura
and i just like to welcome two
colleagues today because today we're
here to talk about the
smoke-free policy in one pediatric
district council
um so it's my pleasure to welcome lee
tuki who's a partnering in this um
presentation um so leaves from the
community in public health
with cdhb and um
awesome feel free to have a seat um
if you'd like to and and gabrielle just
while the seating just to
say welcome to your offices to our
district it's great to see you here
and the positive uh went to your runway
event a couple of weeks ago it was
fantastic
uh not that i bought anything there
because it's clearly it wasn't clearly
um for me but um there were a number of
people that were and i'd say it's a
fabulous event and welcome to our
district i think
um a cancer society is a welcome
addition there are all the work that
you're doing so thank you
and for those that don't know gabriel's
brother used to work for us so
mark so um it's nice to
yeah so thank you in your hands martian
uh tina kota koto tenei
hi everyone my name's leigh and i'm here
with my colleague martin witt from the
cancer society
and we are both members of the
smoke-free canterbury so we're here
today with
the korowai wrapped around us as well
and
thank you for the opportunity to come
along and talk to you
to support the
paper encouraging extensions to the
current council smoke
green spaces policy we congratulate
the waimakariri district council as
early adopters to smoke-free outdoor
spaces
with the 2012 you adopted the smoke-free
green spaces policy
and with an aim to extend all to
all green spaces and civic spaces
using a stepped approach starting with
12 key parks
and more recently in 2018 with the
business zones
one and two public spaces policy
supporting smoke-free and vape-free
outdoor dining and that's discouraged
voluntarily so it's not
not an enforcement one but it's a
voluntary commitment
so last month was the regulations coming
into effect
seeking to increase the range of
controls on vaping products
aiming to prevent the normalization of
vaping and protect young people from the
marketing
and promotions and encouraging council
to extend the current smoke-free policy
endorse the inclusion of vaping thereby
levelling up what was planned in 2012
and later 2018. i'd like to now hand
over to martin
caro macbook members
it kind of escapes your attention that
vaping has received much
uh attention over the last few years now
without effective regulation new zealand
has seen
many types of vaping products around um
and sadly some normalization the
counselors will have received a briefing
paper from us
about what vaping is so i don't propose
to
to dwell too much but suffice to say
both
the cancer society and cdhp uh
retain a cautious watch on vaping
we recognize that vaping may for some
people
provide them with a way of quitting but
the honest answer is we haven't seen
vaping
long enough to know what the long-term
effects are
so we retain a cautious approach and
certainly do not advocate that they are
normalized any any further
on that basis just briefly uh vaping
products are not seen as lifestyle
products the
ministry's advice is that uh vape to
quit
but if you don't smoke don't start and
certainly don't
uh start vaping now there has been
a lot of concern about the exposure that
young people are getting to the
persuasive messages of vaping
and i think it's fair to say that now uh
we are seeing the evidence and new
zealand study
uh has has looked at the levels and
certainly a recent study
of um youth showing that 48 percent of
vapors had never smoked cigarettes
before
so we we are concerned about an emerging
market that we're seeing
new entrants into the vaping market if
you like
some vaping products have low high
levels of nicotine which could
affect the cognitive development of our
youth
the long-term effects of vaping as i
said
is is not known so the the clarion call
is
is one of caution from public health
um public health networks
the question is why would council expand
their existing smoke free
policy well as i said my colleagues
already set out the fact that you were
an
early adopter and if you look at the
policy it clearly indicates the
intention
was to roll it wider than the original
12 parks the
um it would be consistent there to do um
to do that
and also to consider extending the
perimeters
of your building i noticed already the
library has a sign
saying please do not vape or smoke
outside the library
that's an excellent initiative and i
think if we can see all our civic spaces
as was originally
intended in the plan to actually uh
become smoke-free vape free we really
are sending out a very
positive message to our communities um
we know also
that the vaping already is incorporated
in your smoke-free in your
civic spaces your business policy so the
leveling up as we say
would be entirely consistent with your
later
intentions and you wouldn't be alone
many councils are starting to revise
their policies
we now only have three police three
councils in the entire country
sorry thank you
there are only three councils in in the
country that do not have
a smoke-free policy and many are now
starting to adopt vaping
and it can't fail to escape you that
that a council
south of the wymac recently did so um
the overall message is that to include
vaping is to
send out that positive message the next
generation it's consistent with your
later policies
and also it is thinking about the
environmental impact of both tobacco
waste if we're extending the tobacco
policy of the smoke-free policy
and vaping waste in terms of stewardship
and overall it contributes
to a safe and healthy community
my colleague lee will now close the
continue and close the
submission thank you thank you matin
review of the smoke-free green spaces
policy
provides an opportunity to look forward
and see the potential for expanding
smoke-free public spaces
do they work good question and we get
that asked a lot
smoke-free voluntary policies have
proven to be acceptable
to the public as more and more people
are concerned about their health and
health impacts and environmental damage
locally
if we look at the recent smoke-free
vape-free six-month trial that we had in
hamner springs
nine out of ten visitors seven out of
ten residents
and six out of ten businesses supported
smoke-free vape-free zone becoming a
permanent feature of the village
the hiranoi district council then
endorsed the zone
becoming a permanent feature for him the
springs
smoke-free policies such as the
waimakiri the district councils
reflect the tide of public opinion as we
see smoking
prevalence fall one mickey my
waimakariri district council has the
second
equal lowest smoking prevalence in the
south island
with 11 nationally it's 13
good signage coupled with consistent and
positive communications would support
the policy
signage can be rolled out as part of
sign renewals
process for the council including new
developments
as they become operational smoke-free
canterbury welcomes an
opportunity to work with the waimakariri
district council
on any policy extensions and in
particular with support
will support any hospitality businesses
wishing to encourage smoke-free
vape-free outdoor dining
via the fresh air project with free
signage
are we on the last one we are these are
great pictures
so why make it early district council is
changing and you can see it
new town centres civic spaces that seek
to achieve
vibrancy and distinct characters
places that people like to go to and
return to
spaces that support health and
well-being of residents
extending current smoke-free policy
not only fulfills the 2012 original
intentions
and it aligns with the later 2018
business zones policy and public opinion
alte aurora has a goal to be smoke free
by 2025
waimakariri district council is already
making a huge contribution to
achieving this today is an opportunity
to strengthen that commitment
norada tena koto
we're really happy to answer any uh
questions if you have any
well kia ora and and thank you uh
gabrielle martin and lee for the
presentation
just an advance of questions similarly
um proposed that we also request a
report
to come back to us to consider further
the thoughtful submission you've put
forward to us today so thank you for
your time
just ask for any questions from
colleagues
councilwood
i'd just like to ask what can you do or
what is happening
about selling vaping products to
under 18 year olds i happen to know
that they are receiving them they are
seeing
from christchurch and they are receiving
in the mail vaping products
to under 18 year olds so what can we do
to
i think eradicate this both answer a
little bit of that can't we
the straight answer is that the new
vaping rags have come
in which will progressively make
uh vaping uh inaccessible to youth
is it ideal personally speaking no but
at least we have regulation
uh where somebody is being
knowingly um you have recourse i think
leads fair enough to actually write to
the dhb yes
and then we follow up um with that we
have a smoking enforcement officer
within our team
and they certainly do follow up with any
places who do sell to
under 18 year olds um and in alignment
with the regulations that are being
rolled out in the staged
approach so not everything at once so
last month they're brought out anywhere
that there's
no smoking there's no bay bank so that
was part of the regulations
yes it was but i think we we have to
acknowledge that um
currently because we've had three years
of um
vaping rolling out it's it's started to
to to get a grip
an example of of of how this is coming
about is that
the vaping industry is now producing
material which clearly acknowledges that
it can't sell to 18.
but i was shown something last week that
was a deliberate
uh notice that was saying we can't sell
but mum and dad can bring you into the
shop
that's invidious so we um
have what they call control purchase
operations within
um the smoke free and now it'll be
including vapefree
where we go out to people who sell
cigarettes and educate them
that they can't sell to anyone under 18
and then we go
out with a young person in a controlled
environment that's why it's called
controlled purchase operations
and they go in visibly no extra makeup
or anything
or the young guys might not wear the
makeup but um
to try and buy cigarettes and if that
place sells to them or sells
the vaping products um then we can
um
all right well well thank counts to
brine
i've been off cigarettes now for a free
year and
i'm vaping and since the local dairies
are no longer allowed to sell me the oil
i've had to go online to
to get my oil it's a tick box to say
that i'm 18.
and that's all it is
it's um i would be uh it would be
a lie to say that i'm satisfied with the
regulatory framework uh if you compare
it with the approach taken in australia
our approach is lamentable in that sense
however um
some framework is better than nothing
which is what we had last year
but i acknowledge you're absolutely
right it's a little bit of a pass
okay any further questions council
redmond
thank you first of all i should say i'm
a non-smoker and a non-vapor
um good what
what chemicals are in the vapor compared
with smoke
that make it harmful although you say
there is no
evidence that vaping is harmful
uh could you clarify that well i think
that the fair point is
that the the act of burning the tobacco
generates the chemicals which which
are harmful what we're seeing
is that there are a whole range of
chemicals in the vaping product
the evidence is that we used to say
they are safer that has been revised now
and i think the consensus is they are
less harmful
so it's a whole cocktail of chemicals
and the straight irises
we do not know what the long-term
exposure
to the vaping chemicals so it's a whole
cocktail
so the approach is they may well
help some people to quit and if that is
the answer
then that's fantastic but the retention
of the vaping habit longer term
is the questionable as is the
introduction to vaping as a non-smoker
so the straight iron says we simply
don't know what the long-term effect of
those chemicals are
but there is sufficient evidence to
cause doubt and certainly places like
the american lung cancer foundation
are very concerned about evidence
they're seeing in lung damage
and our own colleagues here have
reported the physicians
in new zealand are seeing lung damage
in younger people that they would have
only seen after a lifetime of smoking
so in other words the question is is
lung damage being telescoped
sorry is lung damage being i have this
relationship
go away i don't need you you have a
here with with you know the the
chemicals we simply don't know
but the clarion sort of message is
what we're seeing in younger people
serves to remind us and for those sort
of looking back
we need to learn from what we've seen
tobacco
the messages that are coming is that we
know what
happens longer term with tobacco let's
not make that mistake with something in
20 years
and the next generation of saying why on
earth
did you let people vape i have children
saying
i can't accept that you didn't know
smoking was harmful
the reality is that we all know but at
some point until the 1950s
researchers thought it might be motor
vehicle emissions or things like that
the reality is we need to learn from our
public health experience and be cautious
support people to quit but don't
encourage and normalize this product
because we just don't know
all right i will well thank you um
gabrielle
martin and lee for your submission this
afternoon as i say
uh we will call for a report to come
back probably to our february council
meeting
and um we'll make sure you get a copy of
that
we really appreciate it thank you so
much for your time thank you thank you
all right um we're now at item 5.3
so gonna invite denise kevin and
deardread if you want to come forward
would you like would you all three of
you like to come forward
give me time again right we perhaps need
a third chair at the front as well
thank you oh there is three i'm sorry i
didn't see a third chair sorry pun mate
i can only see two
[Music]
this is good
are you okay are you okay there we could
get you we can get you a lower chair if
you'd prefer
would you prefer enough i think sorry
you're okay
here we are how's that
i've got short legs there's a lever on
the side kevin if you want to
adjust the vehicle yeah you're okay
all right hold on
that's all right we're in your hands no
rush you just let me know when you're
ready
all right well um welcome denise kevin
and deidre to our table
it's great to have you with us um from
night to hariri runai
um so we're in your hands up to 10
minutes to make some points around
the tuahiri area in terms of speed
limits
and speed related matters and
then there may be some questions from
colleagues and as i said to you before
uh item repo report 9.1
actually covers some of this so i'll
take that straight after your
presentation so you
if you'd like to you can stand here
discussion around that so
we're in your hands welcome to our
meeting
my name is denise hamilton and
councillors of waimakariri district
council
i'm on my left is my husband kevin kevin
hamilton and on my
right is deirdre carroll we're here
not only representing the renault we're
here representing the residents of
tiwahiwi
okay and we've got well i've got
three issues three taki i want to bring
to the council
and you've heard some you've heard all
these takis
going back a few years now i brought
them to the council
quite a few times you're not the first
me i bought the movie
before i brought them to two other
mayors
that have been at the wide recognition
council
so it's just being repetitive repetitive
repetitive
so hopefully we're going to get
somewhere this time
so our first our first issue is the
speed limit through to a
week so um i drew up a map
you've probably seen it because you
would have seen this map from last year
when i
i'm not a good um map drawer or anything
like that
if it's anything like what i've seen
before i think it's a pretty excellent
map you should have a job in our
indirect
engineering department this job job
going there perhaps oh
[Laughter]
but since i did this one up though and
we've since talked about it we've got
i said 70 we're wanting maybe we're
wanting 60 now
so that there's just one difference okay
so i'll just
hand this around
okay
and um my other colleagues here they
might have something to say about the
sea
speeds through here then i'll carry on
with my other tuffy
i'll kill
nice to see uh it's nice to see some of
my generation from when we grew up
on a table like this we once upon a time
used to joke and talk about it down the
riverbank
and now it's happening
um look i've lived in tuahiri all my
life i was born there
so when covert came it was like going
back to the old days
we didn't even have a we had one or two
cars down around two o'hawe and it was
absolutely perfect and
it did it brought back quite a lot of
memories to me
but now of course today
as you would know mr brian
we have a lot of fast cars
unfortunately my tucky is after midnight
because i i i call the police quite
often
in fact last night i had somebody uh
down the corner called deadman's corner
at my
corner uh donut until
all the tires blow boom boom boom
and then all the tyres blow and um
i honestly don't know how to get these
cars to go go away to get
they're never there in the morning
because i'm
i'm on my own so i don't go out on the
gate or anything like that and try and
save them to go away
i just stay inside my house and bring
all my animals inside
so we're having a lot of uh a speed
going through to ahi
uh if you came down my road which is
church bush road you i don't have to
tell you you would see all the black
marks
um we also are having
um and i say to when the police do call
they came at lunchtime yesterday
i said could you come back at midnight
you know we get frustrated
uh so they came to find out um
what i was doing ringing the police and
i said well i can't tell you now because
they're all gone
but you can see the marks and that's
they do they see the marks
they're just i feel that
i feel that just as
feel a little bit can't do anything like
we can't
um so it's a hundred k's past my house
um i also have a sign up that's gone up
at the end of the road go
um it's called a heritage trail
so now my hair is your heritage trail
that you are advertising
is bringing um all the all the
uh sports cars some some weekends we've
got sports cars some
weekends we have vintage cars
it's quite nice to sit in my lounge and
watch them all go past
but my question is how come it became a
vintage trail
trail without me knowing and what does
that actually mean
um and so we've got a lot of walkers
a lot of walkers through to a hawaii
because you all want to be fit and live
longer
you're coming from what end but we've
got no footpaths
so everybody's walking on the middle of
the road
at 100k so
we are asking the council please could
we it could
just be looked at i'll hand it back to
the next
thanks deirdre kevin
and residents um
i've lived in two here of i've spent
most of my life around to here one way
or another
we've now lived there permanently for
the last
14 years my major concern
is the safety of pedestrians
and residents through tohiwi and that
extends from
the five crossroads down
to the rivers road um
lionside road area george bush road
par road greens road and don't ask me to
pronounce
but the behavior of most
of those in cars and motorbikes
is getting to the stage where it's
unsafe what
anybody walking through or around to a
huey
takes their life in their hands
on a number of occasions driving
through around i've watched
young mothers with push chairs
struggling in the long grass
because they're pushed there by traffic
at speed
[Music]
and since a lot of the development
around europe
namely the um traffic lights etc etc
two here he's now become a rat run
particular times of the day
the other one is that concerns me as
living
close to the school and the preschool
there is the safety of our children
we have mothers living on greens road
that are scared to let their children
walk to school or
cycle to school because of the traffic
and the behavior of traffic
and the speed of traffic on greens road
through to a hilly road it's like a race
track
uh the behaviour of parents dropping
their children off and picking them up
at two every school
and my view is abominable and
as problem of safety for children
the latest example happened actually
this morning
you're probably all aware of the sports
ground at tahiwi
and here the configuration of the road
there
well there's an area where the
there's a grass there extends to the
edge of the star steel
we had a bus park there this morning
and mothers or our parents dropping
their kids off
we're having to cross the center line
to go uh south ontario road
to avoid traffic
or and then there was pushing traffic
heading north onto a hilly road
over onto the grassed area
while some were parked
where probably the bus should have been
parked but
the gen is just that but the major thing
is
speed and
i've seen so many close shaves
with children and with what people walk
in cyclists
and the speed needs to come down
and it needs to be slowed permanently
because we are it's only a matter of
time before we have a serious accident
and it scares me the number of close
shaves that i've seen through there
and with the number of people walking
through there
for recreation cycling and like say
mothers with children and pushed years
and that we need
a safe walkway and i believe it should
come from the five crossroads
through to rivers uh
through to line side road
that's that's just my general i'll leave
it so what we're putting towards the
council today
is to seriously seriously
look at the speed through to ahead
that's what we're asking you
because like like we're saying we don't
want to bury
anybody there sure you know and that's
what it's hit that's where it's heading
and we don't want it to be a child
that's the thing
a child we don't want to bury a child
so we're asking the council to seriously
look at that
then so we'll go off that we'll go off
that one
there's other issues that we've got as
well what we look
what we want the council to seriously
look at as well is
a walkway or a cycleway for safety for
our people to walk and our children to
walk to school
and that's another thing as well plus
the lighting the lighting into a hearing
at night
is ridiculous it is ridiculous because
there's only certain parts of the area
where you got lights in there
but there's the light you've got you've
got to see you should come through too
heavy at night to have a good look
otherwise what's the point of having
right see because
excuse my language but i was gonna swear
but it's serious it's really serious
there so
that's what we're asking the council can
you please look at two
heroes seriously we feel
i feel too that
with not having any footpaths if
you the council are looking at helping
us and to ahead to get a footpath you're
also helping woody end
wooden people are coming to touahi
because it's just on the outskirts and
they love the walk
around touahi because we're all sort of
like a bit of a farm
and so if you counted how many people
walk that block because it must be a a
good block to walk
if you want to counsel people know
because you walk it
yeah yeah see uh so
so maybe you can share with them how
it's like to dodge the cars
because we've seen the changes that
you're doing around in kaiapoi
and rangiora here with the with the
rating and the speed limits
that's going on because it says in the
paper or you know i
bought the cutouts from the paper that
all these things are going on in our
community in waimakariri
so what about poor old chuwa here we
okay that's what i'm saying
thank you thank you thank you so much
some questions from colleagues but okay
but just we're going to deal with the
speed issues today
the first part of the speed issues the
footpath meter
staff are preparing a report to come to
us so that'll come back
to us as well as the lighting so we're
not
addressing the footpath or the lighting
today it's about the speed limit but
we've heard you
made some very good points as you always
do and you're always welcome here
uh we value um your opinions so thank
you very much
um questions from colleagues kirsten
um very nice to see you today again
and you we are looking at the speed
limits but
what i wanted to just ask is obviously
there's some rat bags around
you've noticed doing the donuts and
things even
if the speed limits go in
do you believe that the speed will
actually come down how will we change
the driver behavior because people don't
always take notice of the signs
well i wasn't just if you notice on
on the map i had those little lucky
lucky's got along the main street over
right here there's those humps
that's what i'm asking for as well you
know
something to slow them down we need
something to slay them down
and my answer would be i would would
like to go into consultation with an
expert
to tell us how to do that because we are
not the experts
we need the experts to come in and help
us
to actually slow the traffic down
have a safe walkway for our children
there is lots of opportunities and lots
of
options into ahi we have these things
called the paper roads and i know
a lot of you may not know what a paper
road is
but you've closed them down and i would
like to see you
look at them as well as maybe getting
the people
off the roads and onto these paper roads
with cycleways now i can't remember the
last mayor i talked to i think it must
be
no it was a high school teacher for this
day it is um
because i it was a map that
comes through to touahi residents about
walkways that you the council were going
to do
and you were going to i'm so pleased
you're
you're nodding mr blacky because i tell
you i can't find the map
but you talked about incorporating the
walkways that you've done down ring your
road
into a kiwi and around the river
you followed the river you didn't stay
on the main
on the main road you actually took the
cycleways
and the do you know what i'm talking
about
please i would like you to readdress
that
that was a very good plan it came right
behind my house
and there's a bit of no man's land at
the back of my house
and i go and spray it and mow the lawn i
keep thinking when's the council coming
to do something or that
and it's quite a big area it's like
about uh half an acre
yeah okay look look thank you for your
time
i i'm sorry to hurry you but we've we've
got joanne's report coming up look can i
say thank you again for coming
um it's really important that we hear
from you and if you'd like to remain
please take a seat because we're going
to discuss the report that deals with
speed issues today
um joanne's going to do a presentation
to us now
following there will be some questions
and probably debate that we'll ensure so
you're welcome to remain
if you've got time and you'd like to and
you can sit at the front here if you'd
like if that's easy
thank you very much thank you for your
time thank you
and i see i see what a couple of my
colleagues have taken uh um
um a couple of photos of your great maps
so
um uh is jura jurids behind us
if you're looking for a future mapper
denise is here so
thank you denise thanks so much
thank you all right
thank you and if you just like to come
forward i'll just quickly we've got no
adjoined business
um we'll come back to we've got no
covert
19 recovery planning or shuffle ready
projects today
so we'll now go to 9.1
and reports uh two ahead to ashley speed
review pages 88 to 150.
i'm joanne thank you thank you
this report is to provide an update on
the speed limit review process which has
been undertaken for the tua huey ashley
area
and to seek approval for some changes to
the speed limits
consultation was obviously carried out
quite some time ago back in august 2019
regarding changes to speed limits and a
report was brought to council in july
this year and was left to lie on the
table so that further work could be done
around whether a 40 kilometer an hour
speed limit could be
implemented through tuahiwi
since that time we have had a further
hui
which was very well attended
and was organized by denise and given
and that at that highway again was an
opportunity to reinforce
um the issues that the community held
very strong in their heart in terms of
safety particularly through the through
the village
we've done some further design work and
consulted with
nzta on a
package of traffic calming measures that
would be required
through the township to support a 40
kilometer an hour speed limit
that plan is attached to the report
and it does include some additional
raised platforms through the village
to make sure that we do get the
compliance with the 40 kilometer an hour
at this stage we are suggesting that
changes be made to uh
yes sorry there's a table under
recommendations
and the reduction of some of the sealed
roads within tuahi from 80 to 100
including greens road and church bush
road
but we are saying that we need to just
hold the unsealed roads
because we are recommending they are
reduced to 60
and there will be further consultation
required
on those roads so
what we were planning or what we would
like to do is
um the physical works would be carried
out in conjunction with the shovel
really project which was planned through
tuahe
and that is likely to start in around
about february next year
so we can look at implementing the speed
limit at about the same time
that that work occurs because we will
need the physical works to reinforce
that 40 kilometer an hour speed
we have been in contact with the
preschool and are also following up with
the school
around safety of children at the
crossing after
during the morning our drop off and also
the afternoon and can talk with them
about
issues such as the bus drop off as well
so i'm happy to take any questions any
questions
council williams followed by councillor
barnes
yeah i'm concerned about our
consultation on some of these speeds
and we've just heard from our presenter
here about
other matters not being consulted um
i know 2019 we did some consultations
but have the actual people on the roads
been asked what they want for their
roads
um yes sir this went out uh
district-wide the consultation
but um we have had now two hues
um around speed limits in the tuahiwee
area so we definitely have been seeking
feedback
so i'll specifically mention monroe
rebels road
have the people down there be notified
the individually everybody in the
district has been notified
um through a series of different
platforms so
that is via news stories via web pages
have we dropped a letter into every
single letterbox
no we haven't but we have tried to reach
as far as we possibly can
with that you know with the information
and we held a drop-in session
at the mirai just to make sure that we
were i guess trying to get
um involvement from the community
thank you council banner yes thank you
joanne for the report
and um quite comfortable with most the
speed limits
but i do note on page 110 of our agenda
revels wrote hit the assist safe and
appropriate speed of 100 kilometers per
hour
um under the under the engineering
requirements
how are we going to justify making it 80
to the general community when it's been
assessed as appropriate to be at 100
kilometers an hour this is on page 110
of the agenda
yeah i'm sorry i don't have
page 110.
i'm sorry i would have to go back and
have a look at that one
i'd be a little bit surprised if it was
a hundred to be honest
just because there uh in terms of
assessments that are based on a number
of criteria including
yeah i am wondering that because it is
based on a number of criteria including
personal collective risk and also crash
history
and i do there are very few roads
that would actually qualify for 100 and
even limeside road
doesn't qualify at 100 so i suspect that
maybe an
error thank you just second question
very quickly um
this if tuahue village goes down to 40
um is that then setting a precedent for
other villages in our
district um such as of similar size such
as cast
or even sefton who currently have 70 and
60 respectively
yeah that's a really good question and i
think to a degree
yes it probably does i think it reflects
an expectation from our community to
actually
have more safe and appropriate speeds
around
our urban areas and what we do need to
acknowledge
is there will be additional cost for us
and and implementing these because we
have to
engineer that environment um
so that will be something that will be a
challenge going forward
okay further questions council award
followed by council blackie uh just a
quick question when we do
um the the shovel ready project which is
going to
improve the touahe area for
stormwater and and connecting through
into the eastern district
scheme um once we've done that
would would part of that be the repair
of that
could that be made into footpaths and
cycling way once
once that's completed so
what's happening with that is the
majority of the work
as i understand it they are trying to do
the pipe installation by trenchless
technology where possible so drilling
where they can
there will be some trenching required
it's more likely to be in the
carriageway
rather than an area that could be
reinstated as a path
but look we are doing some work as dan
mentioned
around walking and cycling connections
and that's something that's very much in
the forefront of our mind and we will be
bringing to council
going forward great that's wonderful
thank you thank you council blicky
um i think so what we did is uh
we set that southern limit for
where the speed limit currently changes
and that is basically the edge of the
urban
area so where the houses are the issue
is
if we push it out further to the south
and to what is more predominantly
a rural feel is that again we will have
likely have very low level of compliance
with it
and potentially very high entry speed
because it feels rural
um we likely to struggle to get the
compliance
and it's always a really difficult
balance that we're trying to
achieve in an area like that so that's
why we haven't
i don't have the council in my mind um
but i don't believe the volumes are very
high
thank you council atkinson thank you mr
mayor
just following on from council about
index um
so the process that we've gone through
here
is consultation and and directed from
the community
if the other communities were to raise
it's around this precedent
that i'm sort of getting to um if it was
raised from other
communities we would have is it is it
right that we would have
um the same sort of consultation with
those communities individually
and we would be able to program those
works if there was any
inappropriate years is that my
understanding of a process if indeed it
was raised
um i mean this process has been raised
for years
if we were to start that process that we
understand yeah and i think we would
need to do that
because we wouldn't be able to do
everything in one big go
it would be a matter of staging or
prioritizing programming
i think in terms of
i guess national direction the road to
zero
strategy certainly in the way this
government
is focusing around transport there is
very much a national directive to look
at more
safe and appropriate speeds particularly
in urban areas
to that given that both of those
particular roads one's
the ex state highway 73 and it was of
higher volume
and certainly through um shifting as
well
i was actually wrecking my brains that i
was trying to ask these questions
is there any other areas such as
touahiwi that
this could sit precedent too that's not
on
like in each state highway or an
arterial road you know it's on the
similar type
road not that i can think of i guess off
top of my head
i would say with cast um
trying to get a 40 would probably be a
little bit of a stretch
i think probably a 50 might be more
appropriate and we would have to go
through that assessment
it's obviously 60 at the moment and then
there's also questions around things
like variable speeds outside of schools
and those sort of things that we could
look at
so at school start and finish time
one thing over the next 10 years we will
be looking at all of our schools
in again with a drive to get safe and
appropriate speeds outside of schools
the beaches we tend to have low speed
limits but then we don't have the
through traffic
um oxford is probably a similar
situation where we have had calls for
lower speed limit
than the 50 that's currently through
there um
and again we about we have to balance
that because we have a lot of heavy
vehicles as well going through
oxford so we've got some challenges in
front of us
um that we'll need to work through okay
i think uh council began for the
question
yeah so currently um the setting of
speed limit rule
does not allow a council to set a 70
unless it has an
exit plan for how it will get a
transition there to either
an 80 or a 60. what i would say
is there's some thinking at the moment
though around
and i think a lot of feedback from
councils has been
that this is not working um and that the
70s
and potentially 90s also need to be
included so
i understand legislation change may be
on the horizon
okay all right well with that um thanks
joanne for your report i'm i'm going to
test the
meeting and move the recommendation
that's contained in our report
probably the summary report's probably
the most accurate one
so do i have a seconder second to buy
councillor atkinson
justin speaking to this can i firstly
acknowledge
i think joanne you and the team have
done an excellent job
in the preparation of this it's been
extensive the consultation that we've
undertaken
we let the matter lay on the table
because we weren't satisfied
that we were going to achieve some of
our community's expectations and i
particularly acknowledged naidu hiri
and the excellent work that they've done
in terms of
getting people to a meeting to start
with so
i understand that both kevin and denise
let drop the entire area and so when um
council blecking and myself went along
with the meeting with you we're
expecting quite a small audience well we
were quite surprised it was
very extensive and so really well done
so
again we might have a talk to you about
how we get more people to our meetings
in the future but
um well done because it did really
clearly reflect
the support not only for the local
village and
the mirai but also much more broadly
into a hearing of the need to look at
change
also we weren't satisfied with the
response that we got from
nzta which initially wasn't to accept
that speed limit change
through the village we noted that it was
really important
to our local roonaga and so the deputy
mayor and myself whilst
in wellington for another meeting saw
the meeting with the chief executive of
nzta to make it clear
our position and i know that joanne you
had also worked on that
we just not long ago also had a meeting
with jim harland
with denise kevin and deidre where those
points were made again
and that's it's taken a bit of work but
we've got to where we need to be
in terms of what's uh in terms of the
village and there will be some changes
required in that environment to support
that but there are changes that we think
are worth it because our community
have certainly indicated that so
hopefully today we'll tick the first one
off the list
as was mentioned earlier more broadly
and g which notes the other areas which
are looking at different
uh limits um i think it's appropriate
that they're put on hold until we have a
more broader conversation
and hopefully by then we may also have
some further clarity from government
around their thinking around speed
limits but
it's important that they are also
addressed
as well it's it has also been mentioned
there the priority of a footpath
and linkages so that will be subject to
another report
uh and also the lighting as mentioned
earlier as well
uh it was talked of before a council of
barnard around
um other communities and sitting
precedent
i'm sure we will have discussions with
other communities but as i can see this
this is on a case-by-case basis and
we'll deal with those
as they come up and open to those
conversations with communities we've
come up with all sorts of solutions
over the years i remember being involved
in the swananoa school
some years ago when we came up with a
creative solution there so
this council has showed that we are
prepared to listen to our communities
take on board their concerns and come up
with solutions
uh that have that community buy-in it is
only going to be effective if people
observe it
in the environments one thing but as i
mentioned to
to kevin denise and deidre at the
meetings we had if we if they know of
particular vehicles offending let us
know what the
um who they are particularly big big
heavy trucks which is a concern and we
can talk about
uh to those particular trucking
companies and see if we can
divert them from the area uh and um
and address those things through that
way and it's being more proactive in the
management
of the village area itself so look i i
have no hesitation supporting this
because it's been such a thorough
process i think as i
mentioned before thank the staff for
their support in getting us to this
point
councilor atkinson thank you mr mayor i
was
um i actually wasn't going to support
this um
uh to start with uh purely and certainly
that i've read one of the
recommendations on the uh
on the second table wrongly and uh
luckily before we sat down at the table
i read it again and uh
and got it right in my head so it's his
notes and not recommend so that was a
um so that was one of the uh one of the
things that i'd intended to do it's not
that i disagreed with certainly with
what was happening
uh into a week but i do have a general
concern
around speed limits in the way that they
are being handled around this country
and being forced upon people who don't
want them
now tuahu has made it very very clear
about their village for
a long long time and i have no issue
with people
who are in control of their own destiny
um
about where they live and that's fine by
me so i don't have a problem with that
where i do have a problem is where
they're forcing speed limits on
different places
um that um have arguably a crash record
that's
uh that's rather interesting and
statistically collected
in a way that's uh that is um
gathered liberally if you like i always
remember sitting around the road safety
committee
in this council where our motorcycle
deaths had got risen by
uh a hundred percent and um
i was horrified to hear that and i'm
horrified to hear that anyone's killed
whether it's a motorbike car but the
difference was
that it risen from one one death to
actually two but it was a hundred
percent rise but if you read the report
we were living in disaster land and um
while the death as i say is
disastrous and i don't want to belittle
that when you put
some of those statistics into practice
and actually work the numbers out some
of them are not as high as they
certainly seem to be
but this is being forced upon us and
we're just in people's backyards every
five minutes
and i want to make sure that that's done
correctly so questioning
arguing doing all of those things along
the way is what we should be doing
rather than these coming to us
as a director from the government this
is what you will do so i'm very pleased
to hear joanne say
that uh there may be some
re-look at what it is that the
government's thinking around those speed
limits and and what
they may be so i'm looking for that i am
very pleased to recommend this for
that certainly for the township of tour
here because as i say i think it's been
well argued for a long long time that it
has needed to happen and this has been
an opportunity that
that we now have and i think we can do
it without too much problem
president i have no problem with the
president because again
if the community if the community argues
for it
and proves to us that that it does
require that
then we will budget for that at a
appropriate time if we feel strongly
enough about it
if we don't then we won't so um
i think that that's absolutely
appropriate as well so
and it will be different horses for
different courses so
we'll deal with those as they come up so
i
i hope you will all support us thank you
councillor atkinson council
yes today we've taken a really really
good step if this goes through
um and i'd also like to acknowledge the
fact that we're changing the speed limit
of cold stream road
down to 50 and past the new multi sports
facility which is really really
important has
been called for by many people and
saying why hasn't happened already
but now we're underway with that and
also then reducing it from 80
into that other major gateway for an
euro um
i i was reluctant at the beginning with
roads like rebels road because
they look totally rural and people
always drive to the conditions
and we are going to struggle to get
compliance with these speed limits
that's that's a fact um people see rural
and they think rural
but i think we're getting to the point
that we're realizing that rural roads
near urban centres
are different and they this is the new
normal and 80k
is going to be the new normal and i i
don't think we can fight that i think
with the government direction that's
what's
going to happen and in this situation i
think with the amount of traffic and the
growth in our district
it's actually highly appropriate to
start educating people
to pull it back to 80 around these areas
to make it safe
the next step is compliance and i hate
to say this but
it's actually a police matter and we
need the help of the community
we had a presentation from the police
the other day and i was absolutely
shocked
at the very low numbers of police in
canterbury
and a lot of them are being diverted to
the covert
emergency response and that means we
have less police on our roads
we have less police around to actually
catch some of the rat bags
who are doing doughnuts who are doing
130 the police resources are stretched
and i feel really really that we as a
council in our community need to lobby
government and say
this is not good enough if you want
really want road to zero
we need more people on the road out
there catching people doing
those speeds so i would really encourage
the community to do that
the only reason i brought up the other
settlements is i was aware that cuss was
actually due for a speed limit review
this year in 2020
um however it got put off because of
covert 19 emergency
it was due early this year they've been
waiting for years to try and see a
review
and i'm a little bit suspect about the
argument that because it's a major
arterial that a village shouldn't be
treated like a village
i still think we have to be very careful
that we're still looking at the safety
aspects
rather than the that what road it
actually is on
and on what hazards are there and what
the likely threats are
um so we have now got some inconsistency
in our district we've got a 70 at
sifting we've got a 60th cast we've got
a 50 at oxford
all on major arterials um in different
sized villages so we will have to look
at those
and i just want to make it clear that i
really
we need to budget for it we're going to
have to budget for if this is the
direction of the government
we have to put more in our budget in
this area because
government's not going to pay for local
changes to speed limits we
are aware of that we may get some
subsidy but we won't get a lot
to do the treatments that are required
so my my questioning of other areas was
the fact we need to put some budget
short term in our long-term plan council
blackie
councillor williams yeah um
i actually um went down to hebrew this
morning and i observed one of the buses
in the car park and
i was there when the second bus pulled
up and um i was actually horrified with
some of the people dropping the kitties
off to school
the way they pulled in there and um
yeah it wasn't nice and they weren't
observing probably
the inland and lane that's sort of there
to get into that car park so
driver education is quite important of
it
i also went down to rebels road and
talked to some people down rebels road
um they were horrified that we're
looking at dropping it down to 80
kilometers they're
quite happy at 100 kilometers in there
um we have got
statistics and we've got some of the
best roads around new zealand
driving down rebels road i don't think
river roads included in that
so that's the only reason i'd support
rebels road coming down to 80 k's is
conditioned the road if it was a nice
road like it used to be
it's wide it's okay and i don't think
we'll be able to stop people speeding
down the air
one of the person said we've got no
problems with people
traveling a 100k here but it's 150
kilometers there that they all travel
there
all the time and this isn't going to
stop that
um it's also not going to stop the
the way the treatment of people driving
in and out of the school and all that
drama so i think
some education probably may be coming
from the school
side to the appearance that dropped the
kids off as well but
um as i wouldn't be supporting this in
total
if rebels road was actually to our
normal standards of road and i don't
think it is
so i will be supporting this but um the
rebels road was a question in my mind at
the stage
for the speakers just to write a reply
counselor bar that's right to observe
cold stream road and we forget about all
the work that we've done to actually get
the
speed to that level and it came from
submissions to us
around putting footpaths down there to
recognise the safety
which then enabled us because it is a
rural environment
um down there to end with the build-up
of the stadium to get to that point of
of achieving that speed so it's a really
good outcome
and um so it sort of finishes that piece
of work that we've been working on for
some time
i think our police out here do do an
excellent job i pick up the point that
council barnett made but
one of the things i have a regular
meeting with peter cooper
every month and also um we're
very keen to make sure that quarterly we
have an update here
with our police to keep connected with
what's going on
it's a real partnership approach that
we're developing with the police and
it's absolutely appropriate because
they're vital
in our community around resourcing will
always advocate
and support our police because it's
really important
i know peter's very keen and i do when i
get feedback to me feed it into
their system so if these issues that
come up we were noticing that there are
regular issues then
they're agile enough to be able to
respond notwithstanding the point made
around covert and that's a
a different matter that's been directed
from a national level but
certainly at this level here i
personally think we're very well served
by our police and they do a fantastic
job
in our community even though they're in
stretched circumstances and that's
something that we can continue to work
with them on but
all the other points are well made so
i'm not going to i don't need to respond
to those further
so i'm going to put the recommendation
now all those in favor please say aye
contrary declare that carried here we go
denise
the team well done all right
um you're welcome to stay with us for
the rest of the meeting if you'd like
but you don't have to if you don't watch
too
[Laughter]
all right okay thank you very much
we'll just go back now um
to 8.1 and
we've got sorry we've dealt this out of
all that stuff
sorry all right thank you very much
all right so it's under regeneration so
um
it's pages 37 to 87 around
uh regenerationary assignment thank you
we'll let you catch up i know you're all
good uh
council just like to
overview this report uh it
seeks to make some recommendations to
you to respond
to the red zone recovery plan
in a specific part of the district the
kairaki area
and that requires as has been briefed to
you
a number of changes to existing
documents
particularly the deed between
uh the council and and naitahu uh
represented obviously by the local um
people naitou or hurriti uh and then
further to the reserve management plan
that
applies to this land and as has been
briefed to the district planning and
regulation committee but is being
separately reported
and considered changes to the district
plan
i'll take the report as read and i'm
pleased to
answer any questions thanks simon
questions
all right so we come to a recommendation
prepared to move
council blackie seconded by council
atkinson
do you wish to speak to it
you just put your microphone on please
sorry oh
sorry battery's not on it
um excellent um two years two years um
in the making this well a whole lot
longer than that actually
but especially thanks to simon who's
battled away with the trust
um with us for a long long time um
it's pretty it's pretty self-explanatory
now we just need to change the
management plan
um adapt the um adapt assist the
situation into the
into the district plan and um some some
long-awaited for progress thank you very
much thank you
this is a really significant piece of
paper
this is a community that has been
wanting to recover for just on 10 years
this makes a major step towards that
happening
and for our district that is something
that uh
we i don't know if there's ever an end
to recovery i think it just keeps going
and going
however for this community this is a
very major step
and i think we all need to realize how
significant this is
not only for the people down there but
also for the rest of the district in our
recovery
thank you further speakers councillor
edmund
uh if i could just ask simon um if it's
accepted that a lease of 30 years
is a disposition of land what is the
crown's view
as to at least of that duration
and my second point
we had a briefing this morning on the
district plan review
and the implications of sea level rise
um there was no mention of that in any
of this material
including the lease so
first first quest response to the first
question councillor
uh we've had quite a lot of ongoing
engagement with the crown through
department of prime minister cabinet and
land information new zealand
they are particularly mindful of
the enabling provisions and the recovery
plan that sought
to make provision for relocatable
non-permanent uh buildings i think in
doing so they recognize
that to achieve some of the objectives
around vitality
and recovery or regeneration of the
local community you want
longer term occupancy as long as is
prudent from a natural hazards point of
view
so they've been agreeable to a longer
term
leasing period than a shorter term
but the least ultimately from the
council's point of view
is really a matter for the trust
took him to consider with its less ease
if you like i i think the
30 years is understood
and we've attempted to manage the
provisions of the district plan
accordingly and to consider what
future on the basis of the information
that we currently have
the kind of sea level rise scenario
through the district plan provisions
that
at the moment is reasonably expected
on the basis of the scenarios that are
national level scenarios and that we're
familiar with
i think the least document provides for
in the event of change circumstances and
what might
might those be in the event of an
currently unforeseen but still
ever prison
acceleration and climate change
then there are provisions safeguard
provisions in the lease document
around notice to to terminate the lease
in those sort of circumstances
and of course that would trigger the
review provision
for those of you who are were able to be
at the
district plan briefing this morning um
the review provision
in the in the event that sea level rise
reached the the point specified in the
draft plan
i think 4.8 covers the point talking
about um
and the report council redmond because
you've still got to make the building
act if you've
looked at that provision there thank you
mr mayor i was going to say that
until this morning i was rather are you
speaking to this now
i am okay thank you thank you yeah just
clarifying
you jumped off questions quite quickly
and caught me on the hook
i'm just trying to move it because i've
got a number of people signaling
apologies today
thank you mr mayor right briefly i
when i first read this i wasn't
naturally inclined to support it
on the basis that a number of residents
in karaki in particular
had accepted the government offer albeit
reluctantly
and it seemed rather inequitable that we
would return
or revert to a residential use
however after this morning's briefing
this area is susceptible to sea level
rise
and i see this use is really a temporary
interim use of the land which will give
the trust
some income albeit in the short term
so on that basis um i can see that it
can be justified and i've changed my
view
and prepared to support this thank you
great further speakers
council duty followed by council obama i
very much support this
to help the the trust move forward
and and do what they need to do for this
land this that
karachi regeneration area this is just a
no-brainer
not to um support it cassava
is like councillor edmund i had some
reservations about
relocatable buildings going down to
kairaki which is a beautiful area and i
wanted to make sure
that that wouldn't detract from its its
value
but i've been reassured by the trust
document which makes it very very clear
that that is controlled and that the
buildings that may be used there
will be of good quality and a good
standard and will actually
enhance the area rather than detract
from it for the existing residents
so i'm also inclined to support it
thank you and i will also support it i
i'd support the trust
achieving their aspirations there's been
a lot of work go into it by
council atkinson when he's on the trust
and also um lately with councillor
blacky as well
and we've had heard the passion from
greg here at a number of occasions about
it
on behalf of the trust um thanks simon
for all the work that our staff have
gone on
to this it's a tricky matter and i think
you've achieved that balance really well
so it's it's not not it's still a bit of
water to go under that bridge but it's a
positive step
uh in the right direction so thank you
very much
rather reply accounts reckinson oh sorry
counselor blicky pardon me
okay i'll put the recommendation all
those in favor please say i
contrary to clear that carries all right
we now come
to 9.2 thank you simon
so we've got column
and kelly
i was just going to and b while you're
coming to the table that perhaps the
wording should change from that
following lengthy
uh change the word from lengthy to
extensive i think would be better a
better word
yep i'm happy with that
all right so just a quick
question um
somewhere else
okay hold on g
oh it does too so um i think
i think we if the mover and secondary
happy with that i think by
general agreement of the council we can
amend that
accordingly as alright adrian thank you
okay all right thank you 9.2 under eye
yep
okay um we we can correct it as we go so
colin thank you
thank you so this is um reporters on the
familiar topic
of the points road water supply upgrade
um
the that particular topic is around the
work that the advisory groups have
carried out recently
um so we've been working with the points
road advisory group and the west edin
summer hill points road advisory group
to
cover off two matters that were still to
be resolved
after the project got included for
stimulus funding and those two points
are around a scheming contribution
between
points road and west end and summer hill
as a
result of points road joining those
schemes and also how to
um how to deal with the 19 unit
properties on the points road scheme
given that's a different connection type
to what the other two schemes have
so in terms of the scheme contribution
the
points road advisory group came up with
a figure of 168 000
as the contribution and that was based
on
we we went through quite a lot of
analysis of how that could be calculated
and um there are a lot of different ways
you could calculate a figure and in the
end
the group felt it was all very complex
and confusing
more so than it needed to be and
simplified it to a thousand dollars
for um per connection as recognition of
the
existing headworks infrastructure a
thousand dollars per connection and
recognition of the
new well which gave it two thousand
dollars per connection
contribution times by 84
connections from points road gave a
number of 168
000 so that was recommended at the
points road meeting in october and then
in november we
went to the west end summer hill points
road
group and presented that recommendation
and ultimately that group also
recommended
to um that the council adopt that figure
as the to be um transferred from points
road to west end and summer hill
so that was a very positive outcome
because i wasn't actually expecting that
i was expecting to
possibly have to sleep uh slightly
different figures and then council
having to decide which one it thought
was the right one
so it was a really good outcome to get
the groups both agreeing on the same
number
um and then the other point that
was talked about was the 19 unit
properties so the um
just to remind people the
the issue was when we first approached
western summer hill about the idea of
points for adjoining
one of the things they wanted us to
consider was how we would deal with
the um the points right scheme has 12 of
its
84 connections have 19 unit connections
rather than
typical connection sizes are two or four
units and um
that's just due to the history of the
points road scheme that's it used to be
a
semi-restricted scheme when it was first
established and now it's um
[Music]
new connections are fully restricted but
old ones are still semi-restricted so
we said and somehow made the point when
historically they had been required to
reduce their connection sizes down so
what were we going to do about points
road to make it more consistent
and um there had been a lot of history
with points road that was a little bit
different
to well as a water scheme they had
slightly unique histories
among them and so there wasn't a
clear answer but in the end
there was an accepted solution
by both groups which we think is
workable which is that um
[Music]
the 19 unit properties would get
presented with the option to reduce
their connection sizes down to
somewhere in the range of two to eight
units which is typical of what
is on the west end and summer hill
schemes
um but they would retain their right to
at the moment they can redistribute 19
units if they subdivide down to
multiple lots they can then redistribute
those 19 units among
the new lots that they would create and
that would um negate the need to
buy extra units and there had been
correspondence
that's now quite old about 20 years old
but amongst amongst that community um
where they they paid for initial
infrastructure that would allow them to
have those larger connections and i
talked about
the ability to subdivide so
um i was agreed they should retain their
subdivision right but they didn't need
access to that much water in the
meantime
so that was the proposed solution and
then it was still acknowledged there
might be one or two properties on points
road who really do
want to retain those larger connection
sizes
and that if an effect given that no
one's actually using that much water if
they really want to do that and they
are willing to pay for it then they
should be allowed to do so as well so
it's um
i've tried to sum that up in a little
bit more succinct recommendation but
essentially it's saying
that they'll be given the option to
reduce the connections down they'll
retain the subdivision right but if they
really
a couple of them really want to they can
still retain the larger connections
and provided they would pay for it so
that was also
um supported by the westie and the
summer hill group
as uh the most pragmatic solution that
could be come up um that we could come
up with for that
issue so that was also really good
outcome because um
in some of the earlier meetings there it
was um
seeing a lot more black and white that
either you you know if they want to join
our scheme they'll follow our rules sort
of
approach um but having understood the
background that's changed a little bit
now
so the key recommendations in the report
are to include their 168 000
contribution um within the draft
long-term plan so that would still be
could still be um well it would still be
consulted on it could
could still be submitted on during that
period of time but that would be the
figure that goes into the draft long
term plan
and that also the 19 unit strategy that
i described
um be endorsed which would then allow us
to start the one-on-one conversations
with those 12
with points road residents and also
to seek approval to start the physical
works
on the project so as you know this is
one of the stimulus projects
and and that's one of the reasons that
we're
fast tracking things a little bit um so
we have a
price for the to put the pipe in from
our water unit which is within
our budget and estimates and we are
essentially ready to get that underway
or award the work now
to start in the new year um so we're
just
seeking endorsement now that we've come
to
uh solutions that the advisory groups
agree on on these
two key points that um would also give
us the confidence to start actually
constructing the upgrade so i'm happy to
take any questions on that thanks colin
any questions accounts about it
colin i sent you a few questions but i
thought i would ask in the meeting
because i haven't had a reply
um following the public meeting you had
with points road
scheme users yeah um you had said there
was going to be a public meeting for
west theater and summer hill scan users
to bring them along with what was
happening has that meeting occurred or
why not if not yeah thanks for
raising that so we have had a little bit
of discussion on that point
so i in the first instance i think
um we to get us to this point we've
relied on the variety of groups to make
a recommendation
because um this works only just wrapped
up
sort of a day before the agenda for this
report closed so we have to put a figure
in the draft
long term plan so that that's what has
given us this figure to date
and then what we need to think about
next is how we go about consulting on
that figure
um so we
um and we're thinking about
about that alongside the wider stimulus
package it works because this isn't the
only scheme
that has had um you know schemes joining
each other so we've got fernshot and
logan lee
joining eastern districts and we haven't
had a meeting with the eastern district
sewer scheme
about that either so we um and there's
other funding things going on
with the stimulus package of work so
what we're trying to come up with is a
plan
of how we're going to consult across
across all these different projects
we're doing at once that all
involve some kind of schemes joining
with other schemes um
and and to figure out what the best way
to do that is
so um and also alongside that part of
the
uh long-term plan is also consulting
under three which rating review which is
really relevant to summer hill and
western
end points as well so the short answer
is we still need to come up with the
best strategy
for not just somehow in western but all
the three waters projects that are
affected by the
stimulus so we um
don't have an answer right at this
meeting exactly how we're going to do
that but we are thinking about it in the
context of the wider long-term plan and
how we consult on the bigger picture i
guess let me put it another way are you
confident that we see eaton and some
who scheme participants the people who
are on the scheme are aware of this
proposal
and what it actually means for their
schemes
yes definitely they are aware because
after the
pro the planetary project got approved
by council for the stimulus funding we
wrote a letter
and i think early october in 19th of
october that went out to all three
schemes and it told them
this is what the council's agreed
basically what it means is that we
we have to fast track this project and
at the end it said what the next steps
are
which involves the advisory group work
which is covered today so
they were aware that the schemes are
going to join that the advisory groups
are going to work through the
contribution between schemes
and the 19 unit properties and then it
just finished by basically saying it
will keep you in touch with the next
step
so everyone in the scheme will have got
a letter
to say this is happening and that
they'll get further updates as we
progress
with the points that today's report
covers
so that yeah i appreciate what you're
saying
in that sense on page 155 there's a
graph
of the projected water rates for the
relevance schemes
and it notes in the report that there's
a 50 reduction
for west theater and summer hill wasn't
that figure substantially higher when
you first did this consultation
no that's pretty consistent since the um
sorry since the shovel really funding
came in
in order to get equity across the water
schemes wasn't the figure of subsidy
higher
for the summer hill west eastern schemes
i would have only
so the original um before this advisory
group work
the transfer between schemes was at a i
think 199 thousand it's now 168 so that
difference is about
thirty one thousand thank you and so
that's about um
[Music]
uh i can't do a percentage of fifteen
percent-ish difference
so if it's 50 now it must have been
about 60 before
again my percentages aren't great but
you know that kind of thing so i
wouldn't say substantially but it is
slightly
different to what was in that report so
looking looking at that graph on page
and considering that a new scheme is
joining two existing
schemes that are joined effectively
joined
the discrepancy between the rating
between summer hill and points road
how how will that be viewed as equity
equitable by our community
um i i guess i mean the obvious
difference is
that um there was no government funding
available in summerhill
joined and um
and there was when point schroeder's
joined and it's it's obviously if there
was funding when summer hill joined we
would have applied for it and
and it would have been a different
picture so
it it is a matter of you know and
there's
there's many other schemes as well who
haven't got there's very few schemes
that have got government funding there's
two out of our 16 that we started with
in the district
okay yes okay we need to keep moving
forward because
some members want to finish early today
so for that to happen we need to get
through a chunk of this agenda
um council duty
thank you colin i just wondered going on
about the the difference of the 31 000
difference when
when you talked with the other groups
were they
quite comfortable with that because it's
quite a big chunk
less than what was originally asked
yes i think they um the the first figure
i guess was a first cut and they
they were um
[Music]
yeah there was they were they seemed
very happy that
point should come back with a reasonable
offer i wasn't around when the
western summer hill debates went on but
i
i don't think they were as um you know i
think there's a lot more back and forth
to come up with a figure so it was um
i was pleasantly surprised by how well
it was
you know agreed between the two schemes
of three schemes
okay so council williams is indicating
he will move
secondly by counts the meetings house
williams
yes um i'm quite comfortable with this
i've been to all the meetings so far
and um the um some of the
person removed the motion for it and
whisked it and seconded it on the
meeting so it was all
unanimous so we have had communication
with um
all parties and um
i think west et and somerville also are
getting a bit of an upgrade and for the
uh
um
reservoir type tanks as well part of
this um
project so um so they're getting a wee
bit of a win there as well
so um so i think it's it's sound good
i i know we've gotta we actually talked
about having a meeting with the
uh all the groups again before christmas
but
just the time didn't allow for christmas
um
what's happening so um but i think it's
all going good and i think um
colin's presented every time at the
meetings it could have been quite tense
and
it was actually very good presented with
everybody involved
casabellex
yes i i would like to commend you guys
for
for getting to this point that we're at
here now
um there's been quite a lot of rigorous
robust
yet respectful ish um discussion
at times um and and i really take my hat
off to you how you have actually
met that challenge and and come up with
an acceptable and acceptable middle
ground
you know having sat in on on most of
those meetings
one did wonder if we were ever going to
actually find the middle ground but you
have
and i'm very happy to support this i
think that there have been some very
hard questions some very curly questions
asked and answered
and i guess we're just really very lucky
that we have the stimulus
funding to to
apply to this project because that makes
it a
very difficult situation a lot easier to
come to a resolution for
and yes i am very happy to support this
and i do
very much hope that the rest of you will
too
um i'm going to also support it so i
just
moved her in secondary you were happy
with the wording change from lengthy to
extensive
change that yes yes sorry i just saw it
i'd signal that at the start i just
assumed
i'm going to support this as well it's
remarkable i think how our staff make
complex
very complex measures very simple and
i'd like to commend
um colin kelly and all the team jared's
been at
uh all the meetings as well and uh
in cheered um by councillor williams
that they've been very well run meetings
and excellent engagement with our
community so
you've heard me say a number of time
times colin but very impressed with how
you
deal with people respectfully and kelly
and when you're out there fronting with
them
they can be tricky at times but you deal
with it really well and it's factual
you get back to them with the
information they're looking for in
and look when we first went out there it
wasn't looking like we were going to be
getting a solution so the shovel really
certainly did
assist with that i was involved in the
west yet and summerhill
discussions as a member of those
committees council stewart was as well
they were very tricky conversations
indeed
and including the cuss community so when
i look at that and how we've progressed
and learned
with our consultations over the years oh
and
also if we talk about gary mayer as well
we've learned
all the way through about how we can
better engage with our communities
and take them on the journey with us
this is part of that exercise
the the consultation um with the summer
hill
and we're staying communities give you
an indicator and the others you're going
to reflect on
and that's great so we look forward to
hearing where
and how you think you could engage a bit
further with those communities but in
principle
what it's asking us to do today is to
approve it and the long-term plan which
will be available to the community to
consult
to to submit on and endorse that general
direction the speed and haste that we're
going through with this
is because we've got to get to the point
with the shovel ready
works so thank the staff for the work
that they're doing to get us to that
point so thank you
any further speakers council duty
just like to say thank you very much for
all the hard work you've put in
really much really appreciate it and um
the actual behind the scenes
work that you've had to do to get it to
the level where you could present it to
the community thank you that's about it
yes when i first read the report my
first inclination was actually
to vote against it um because i don't
believe we've brought the community
along with us
but when i read number c and it says
inclusion in the draft long term plan
that does mean that we now give western
and somali residents a chance to submit
on this plan the reason i say we haven't
brought the community with us
is this has been rushed um the whole
covert has upset all the public meeting
schedule it did upset it we had to delay
it
and then there was a meeting for points
road residents now it i
suggested at that time that summer hill
residents or we see it in resistance
could go to that public meeting
to be brought along with the points road
and it was decided at the time to
restrict it
to only points road residents so that
they could discuss the issue first
and then there was promised a public
meeting of the summer hillary certain
then we had shovel really come along the
stimulus funding we had to say yes to
that and i totally get that
but we also talked when we talked about
stimulus funding the shovel already
about equity across our schemes and at
the moment
we have a prop we just we've created
another problem child
um by making points road lower we're
actually making summer hill the second
most expensive scheme behind gary meer
and that's evident from the graph now i
don't think anyone
except for perhaps the two members of
the who are on the advisory group
actually know that this is the situation
with the rating
when points road joins the two schemes
so i don't believe we've brought the
community with us
the members of that advisory group as
far as i'm aware haven't
communicated anything to the western or
summer hill community
and because we failed to have that
public meeting where we could discuss
all these issues and have it all out on
on in the open um we have not
communicated to those scam members
and so therefore i think it's really
critical that in the long term plan
process
that we make it aware that we stayton
and summerhill are subsidising points
road
for joining if they had to pay what they
had would have paid normally for joining
they would have been paying a lot more
than 168 000
even without the shovel really going in
there so i think we have to be up front
and clear that if this is what we want
we want points right to join we want to
upgrade their water and i completely
agree with that
but you we have to as a council be
fundamentally clear
that we certain and somehow water scheme
users are actually subsidizing this
project
and actually receiving very little
benefit from this
i don't believe they're actually
receiving any upgrades to any water
systems
through this project it's purely for
points road future projects
the addition of a few residents will
make a small difference
and the staff mentioned about other
shovel ready projects and other schemes
it's quite different when you compare
like lo burnley joining the eastern
district sewer scheme
when that raises their rates by like 86
cents
when you're looking at the rates that
summer hill water is paying in
comparison to west eriton
and to points row there's inequity
and i think we have to make it clear as
to why that's there
and why we have put forward to the draft
long-term plan
and that we want these two schemes to
subsidize another one joining
thank you council stuart yeah just very
quickly i
endorse what council obama said as a
user on summer hill
and i i agree that this is a pragmatic
solution to um to bring points road
in and it's two points roads
incredible advantage and it is not to
the advantage
of sunlight hill and west earthen and i
endorse that um well the thing that
brings me along in voting for it is the
pragmatism that's behind it but also the
fact that it does go into the ltp
and will give summer hill and west end
and the
opportunity to speak to it
because as councillor barnett says
summerhill is now the second most
expensive water scheme
and in the district and i would have
been more in favor
of it personally had we taken the
opportunity to somewhat
rationalize across all three and i know
that begs the question about
um a uh i would a flat water rate for
for the whole district but i think that
might be almost around the corner
so this would have been an example of
being able to
go some way towards it but i'm not going
to
stand in the way of um
so just a question to colin and kelly
could you consider as part of your
um report i guess back to us around that
option of relativity please
uh well i would pr would
would that be appropriate is the
question i guess i'm trying to ask there
and and and also as part of your staff
submission
around the consultation with those
communities
with the points that have been raised
can you consider that
just to be clear that's as part of a
report for the
draft draft which will come to us at the
end of january
that will pick up the points that
colleagues have raised
council williams sorry any further
speakers council william's right to
reply
yeah i would just like to pick up um
i don't think i was at one of the first
meetings of the west edition somerville
meetings and all that drama but
my first one was about four years ago
and i haven't missed one since so
i don't know it's been that fast-tracked
to get these um schemes going but
everyone i've been to since has been
on track and i think
everybody pretty much knows what's
happening and
um i think the the big sum of the whole
lot is why
the points road seems a wee bit um
cheaper
it would be normally there it's because
we've got a government subsidy on it and
that's the only reason why there's a web
of disparity
we haven't got that subsidy points road
would have been higher than
the summerville one by quite a chunk so
okay okay thanks council william so i'm
going to put the recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carriage
thank you we're going i'm just now going
to move to 9.3 and then we're going to
break for afternoon tea
so and
grant you joining us yep great
consider the report is read and if you
can just make some
main points that you'd like to kate
thank you kate grant thank you yeah
i so this report is
to for council to um consider splitting
the heritage biodiversity and ecological
funds
into two separate funds and for
delegation of
a new fund devoted to biodiversity to
transfer
from the district planning and
regulation committee to the land and
water committee
and there are there are proposed budgets
um that will be brought to
council as part of the long-term plan
considerations
and um i guess staff
note that council has requested that
they'd like to workshop some options
around fund criteria and eligibility
and we'll we'll look to do that early in
the new year
thanks kate did you want to anything
grant
questions tell us about it
kate biodiversity is going forward
obviously and it seems to be an
increasing area where we want to we need
more
are you satisfied that the fund and the
amount of money we've got
going forward in the long term plan for
the biodiversity fund
is significant to meet the objectives
that we need
[Laughter]
well done delegation um
yeah look this is really kind of making
a statement that we want to get up to
the levels that we're seeing with
with other councils and also with what
we know around requirement for
snas there's no secret the government's
making it quite an important area that
we need to focus on hence some of the
work that we've been doing in forest
dale
and look we're putting more money
towards
the ltp with the likes of arahatiawa
and some of the other projects that
we're looking at as well so
this kind of came out of some of the
discussions that we were having at the
last land and water as well
where we sort of spoke about the fact
that the snakes are
our key area for biodiversity and that's
really kind of reflected in what we're
doing here
is it at the level that an ecologist
would want
i'd probably say no um but the reality
is is that we have to start somewhere
and kind of grow it and come in
incrementally um so that it's
appropriate for our ratepayers
okay council steward okay
moved by council stuart seconded by
council duty council
stewart thank you mr mayor
as grant has said this is a no-brainer
as far as
a lot of us are concerned i would like
to propose that we call
the two funds the waimakariri heritage
fund and the waimakariri
biodiversity fund but certainly
um this reflects uh the focus
that is coming through all over the
place as far as residents are concerned
and also the water zone committee
that we put significant
and increasing monies into enhancing our
smas through the biodiversity fund
and also and i see this
as you'll see here over the 10-year
period for
the ltp that we we progressively enhance
the money on the biodiversity fund
getting up to 95 000
a year which brings us um after 10 years
within uh kiwi of some of our
neighbours now this will be in our ltp
and um i would think that
some of our keen residents may in fact
submit that we get um
295 000 a little quicker than within 10
years
but certainly um it's a start
and we have a large job on our hands um
as you
heard this morning in our briefing uh
we're going from
what have we gone over 113
smas to 229
proposed and a lot of those and then
plus there was some
um unmapped that are still to have um
work done on them and this falls to kate
so
we want to be able to if in fact there
is
evaluation and the keen landowners come
to ask for assistance we want to be able
to
help them so i certainly commend um
uh this proposal for your support
thank you a question councillor atkinson
i'll come to you in a minute
thank you sexy for you mr marin threw
you to the
secondary mover whether we could
actually end one and two
um add the words
in there if that was if the movie and
second they're happy with that
yes thank you so that's so that's been
that's just added to the recommendation
there in um
uh c isn't it b b one and two
yeah okay good point
um council duty thank you um i'm very
much in favor of this
um with the waimakariri biodiversity and
the waimea
waimakariri heritage funds being a 50 50
split it's making it far easier for
those that sit around the table and and
look at these the distribution of these
funds so
that's very much supported and the
waimakariri in front of it is very
important okay
okay further speakers write a reply
i'll put that do you wish to exercise
don't need to exercise and reply the
accounts
let's do it i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary clear that carried all right so
we'll just break now
for 10 minutes for afternoon teeth we
could be back here at 3 30.
that's out in the foyer adrian's okay
all right 9.4 pages 192-231
vj good afternoon
okay so finalization of the draft policy
um came to council in august this year
this report's about finalizing that
um and it's following consultation that
was carried out at the end of october
the overall tone resulting from the
consultation was that submitters wanted
to see the council take action with
regard to climate change those that
don't take the time to submit appear to
be well informed about this issue
this policy is a starting point or a
statement of intent with the action to
be outlined in the climate change
response strategy to be prepared early
next year there's no doubt that climate
change is upon us and its effects are
manifesting more and more often through
disasters such as record heatwaves
wildfires droughts and floods the
2016-20 period is set to be the warmest
five-year
period on record as the offense starts
to be felt more and more residents will
look to council for answers
if you've been watching the news lately
you would have heard the climate in
residence blaming the council for
infrastructure failures resulting in
flooding
one resident said it's meant to be a one
in fifty year flood but i've hit three
so far
the mir was saying that the pipes aren't
designed to cope with the amount of rain
that fell in such a short period
and councils will increasingly find
themselves in this situation
it will be costly to do things
differently but there are huge economic
implications of failing to act
new zealand is currently being seen by
some as big on redrick and low on action
we aren't on track for achieving the
2030 goal of cutting emissions from 2005
levels by 30
our current policy settings don't align
with the paris agreement goal
the government has said it's about to
declare a climate change emergency
i'm anticipating increased action in
this space as a result
the situation will only improve if we
all play our part locally regionally
nationally and globally
adopting this policy is taking the first
step towards ancient
protecting our world for us and future
generations
thanks vijay um questions
councillor redmond
thank you mr mayor uh two questions dj
um the word vulnerable appears quite
often
could you explain the emphasis on
vulnerable people
and how they are to be supported
there is a definition on page eight of
the policy
um but i must admit i don't quite follow
the definition
um climate change affects all of us so
i'm just intrigued with the use of
vulnerable
throughout the policy the emphasis in
the
policy or the menswear amendments we
made came as a result of the submission
and is sort of well recognised in those
writing about climate change that
the most vulnerable populations tend to
be the most affected for example
if you've got lots of money and you
happen to live in a flood area you can
generally relocate yourself and
people that don't have the ability to
have a lot of money don't often have the
ability to do that
and a lot of the
indigenous populations on islands in the
pacific are
more vulnerable than some of us are here
in new zealand so
there is increasingly our emphasis on
people dealing with climate change
policy matters that we look to those
people who
are often already socially or
economically deprived
and the
the definition um came
from i can't remember the document but
it was a new zealand document for
natural hazards i think
it's a well-recognised definition
that was my first question the second
one is that there has
seemed to me a very low response to what
is an important topic
although having said that the responses
were of a very high standard i thought
are you satisfied with the response or
why
why did we only get 22 respondents
we weren't ever really expecting a
higher response to a policy because
policy is not very exciting for people
we are expecting and we did
carry out a limited consultation over
quite a short period
we are expecting to do a major
consultation
drive when we release the climate change
response strategy and we think
because it actually will contain actions
that will affect
people we are expecting to have a lot
more interest in that
council meetings
vijay just at the climate change
coordination group meeting
um it was mentioned that um simon
you know which simon i mean simon had
said with the bang the table
app that three and a half thousand
people engaged with that
consultation about 400 people spent five
or more
minutes on the site and then that led to
the number of people who actually
bothered to make a submission wrong
simon but i'm sure you can answer
um so i think that those numbers that
you're referring to with the
visits engagement that we did so
that that involved leaders to all our
property
owners ratepayers in the district
but about three and a half thousand went
into the site to look at the
house's profile for their property um
look the plus about that tool for this
purpose
is it helps you get to understand the
awareness and then
the engagement and finally until the
people who are sufficiently
engaged to their make submissions
we are still learning how to best to use
that tool and promote it
but as vj has highlighted when we come
to a more substantial
response strategic document
we need that to be not a big surprise
it's already flowed from
heightened awareness what particularly
affected communities
but but we will be making or intend to
recommend to you a
much more substantial engagement program
that goes with that
thanks for that assignment i actually
just realized in my notes that that was
the
the natural hazards thing so my mistake
that was my question was that correct
but
the answer would have been no accounts
right considered followed by counsel
thank you mr mia just vijay on uh 5.2 i
think it is
the fourth ball of bullet point point
from the bottom there protecting the
waikoku beach and other beach
settlements from deforestation
could we not just have protecting the
coastal areas from deforestation rather
than actually mentioning something
someone as they are all vulnerable to
deforestation whether it's pine trees or
whether it's replanting a natives the
whole lot of them are
of our coastal area i just wonder
whether
mentioning waikoku beach i mean it just
doesn't make sense to me when you've got
a beach area right the way through
or a coastal area i should say so
basically i'm
just reporting on what people have said
in their consultation
and so um
it's not making any judgment i'm just
saying this is what people have said so
when we take this list which is mainly
about action
and we're considering our climate change
response strategy that's when we need to
go well that's
the issue what's the best way of
responding and you're right
it isn't just that beach here has it
yeah that particular list is what people
have said as opposed to you saying to us
that is a right sorry
casabana um this i don't know if this is
simon or vijay but
that's the climate change response
strategy when is that programmed for and
do we have budget and the lltp for it
um it's really uh staff
costs at this stage and it's programmed
to start
in the new year so that will be a
as you say much more comprehensive
consultation including youth and so on
look we would want to do a scoping
report to you
in a company that with a draft
engagement plan
and um you know there are particularly
affected parts of the district that we
will need to
be more uh engaged with but it's an
issue that affects the whole community
and we will be bringing to you i think i
might have mentioned it
in the district plan briefing this
morning
a a client a paper on a climate change
scenario
that reflects the best our best
scientific understanding of what the
effects might be across this district in
both inland areas and in coastal areas
and temperature and rainfall and sea
level etc
and so we need we we're thinking we need
to be
as prudently specific as we can from the
scientific evidence that is available
so that people get a sense of what does
it mean for me
and i stress it is not just a coastal
issue
and that needs to be brought without
about scaring people unduly but ensuring
they are well aware
as best we are aware of what is
reasonably now anticipated
to to play out
any further questions i
was going to ask councilman council
mailings indicated before
so you're happy to second that so moved
by
council meeting second by council about
it
yeah thank you for all of your hard work
that's gone into producing this
report and and the policy itself and and
tabulating
all of the responses that have that have
come through
um in the consultation and
honestly i just really want to see us
get on with it
so i'm i'm gonna really leave it at that
i haven't got anything else more
eloquent to say than
well done and thank you and i hope
you'll support this
that's about it yes this is this is
actually probably one of the most
important policies that will adopt this
entire two
because going forward it's going to
change the way we do everything
um it may not happen overnight but we're
already seeing effects
just ask any farmer who's now making hay
in december than rather than january
it affects the entire industry it
affects the the patterns of weather it
affects a whole lot of things
and we're still not quite sure what
we're going to end up with so we have to
make sure that we've got something in
place where we put a stake in a stake in
the ground to say that this is important
and the submitters made it very very
clear most of them that it was very very
important to the district
so i'm looking forward to now seeing as
as councilor milling said the action
points
to actually see where we need to
actually put resources
um this is going to be hard for our
long-term plan at this stage
because it's it's early in the in the
piece
but i suggest that in the next three
year review
um that will be very much to the full we
will have a much higher
picture of what's going on by that stage
thank you i support those comments that
have been made
and it is a starting point and
signalling an intent as vj
indicated before and thanks vijay for
all your work i know you worked
obviously with other staff as well but i
think you've done a really good job
pulling this together and thank you
i signaled at the start of this term
climate change and sustainability was
certainly a priority for me
um that's why i established a portfolio
holder in the space i'd like to
acknowledge
uh council mailings and the work that
she's doing
within our and our staff and pulling
together
and her enthusiasm in this space as well
so thank you
nicky for the work that you're doing
it's really important that we do get
buy-in from people along the journey
because we don't get buy-in it's all
well and good that we can signal
but we do need to have the public's buy
and to make change
as part of that i have seen that there's
a number of councils around and
certainly in canterbury
where there are some portfolio holders
others don't have a portfolio holder or
perhaps as connected in this space so an
initiative i've
recently become the chair of the mayoral
forum climate change group
um and in a specific initiative i've
recommended that was endorsed by the
mural forum last week as a summit of all
canterbury councils which will be held
in march
which will involve a representative from
each of the councils whether they are a
portfolio holder or not
but to come together to talk about
actions that we
should be delivering across councils
really
and if we're to get that by and there
has to be a behind across canterbury
there is
ecan are currently preparing the next
stage report on a climate change risk
assessment and that's just been recently
awarded to some consultants so that work
has been undertaken at the moment
starting and it's
i think around mid next year it's likely
to be reported back so
tim davey updated us on that the other
day
so that work is going on at a regional
level
which we're involved with um through the
working group at staff level as well
so um i think this is being said uh it's
a really important step
and uh agree with council of arnold it's
it's really important issue to
a number of our community particularly
our young people
when we go to a number of forums with
our young people it's certainly an issue
that they regularly raise so
i'm very pleased to see us progressing
along that journey
further speakers counts the blackie
followed by councillor redmond
thank you gotta be brief yes i'll
support it there's a few things in there
amongst the suggestions
um that i don't agree with but that's
not to right now not the time to debate
those and i had to have a giggle on page
196 of the
cdhb with their five suggestions there
in their submission so 19196 here
um five things there we're doing all of
them now and i would have thought cdhb
could focus on getting their own
gaza edmund thank you mr mayor i support
this policy my only concern
when reading it was how will it be
implemented
so i await a climate change response or
implementation plan because i think
that's where
the main change will occur and it seemed
to me we need to start measuring data
set targets and one of the submitters
commented about education so i think
that's going to be very important
and whether this council looks at an
educator
in that space will be something we'll
need to decide
um it seemed to me that every department
in the council including us
really need to get serious at the moment
we're only paying lip service
probably to a very important issue so
this really is the beginning i think
it's a good beginning
but it is only the beginning there's
much more to be done
thank you okay accounts very concerning
look i support this i think it is a good
paper in front of us but the only
the only problem i have with the whole
thing is balance
and it's not vj's paper it's not the
work that's done
by our portfolio holder by our staff
it's actually balance across the country
i mean we've got a we've actually got a
government at the moment is looking
at at declaring a climate emergency
no one even knows what that is and it is
around that communication that
that council redmond has just actually
mentioned you know getting some of those
targets and some of those things
and the communication out there right
what the hell is a climate emergency no
one even knows
when you ask people they all have
different views on what a climate
emergency is
so it is around an educational
message that is followed by the facts
and actually followed up with some
actions that will
that are achievable to actually bring
people with it because if we start at
the
the one end which is a where the world
is doomed
tomorrow um then we're not going to get
anywhere if we start at one
that's uh in a hundred years time we're
doomed then we're not going to get
anywhere
either so we need to get make sure we
have those facts and those balances and
checks and measures in there
that can actually tick some boxes and
make sure that we get some actions done
any further speakers write a reply
this is a really important start
and as a start you know our people have
indicated that this is
important to them and really whenever
you sit in like the
the gc2050 forums and that it's right
across stakeholders right across
pretty much every sector it's important
we all know that
it's undeniable climate change is
happening everywhere now
and there's the question that okay well
what can we in little old new zealand do
but you know we've actually you know new
zealand has put a stake in the ground
and the world's watching us
and we as new zealand as new zealanders
can actually make a drop in the bucket
yes
but we can actually show them how we can
move forward with this and not
self-destruct
and then we are basically proof of
concept we are
are showing the world that it can be
done and that is that can be our
contribution um territorial
authorities like us we're at the whole
face um
and and this this is this is the start
that that we need
to to get going um it's not going to be
easy it's not going to be fast but
you know that the um
obviously the first step in the long
journey
the most important one is is the first
one and i know i just totally screwed up
loud zoo there but you know you know
where i'm going with that
we we just need to really make a start
and and this is it
so please support this
thank you so i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please say hi
contrary to clear that carrie thanks
vijay and simon
okay we come now to 9.5 draft
development contributions policy mike
it's pages 232-281
welcome
good afternoon the purpose of this
report is just to obtain
council approval to take consult on the
draft dc
policy 2021 22
as part of the ltp for next year uh as
you'll
have note there's really just minor
changes proposed at the stage
um really around development
contributions that can be calculated for
capital expenditure which occurs out
beyond the term of the ltp and there's
just
some comment too in there about about
knight to a hariri and
how we would um look to uh
negotiate around con developing
contribution liabilities through
different means through
through a strategy uh so really that's
um oh just to say also that there is a
full review pending in
2223 for the the for the um this policy
and the policy is actually now in a new
format to better readable
it's it's with what the startup guy we
have for the council and also
every other policy in the policy manual
that's coming in is in that same style
same format so i'll just leave it
there and take any questions
thanks mike any questions
counselor becky
the 873 dc situation
can you just explain what you mean by
that um you know at mahita we haven't
come to any decisions on what we
can or can't do there yet i just don't
understand what you mean by
consideration of the merits of a
separate apology or strategy enabling
flexibility
can you enlarge on that or even
for that i'll have to defer to simon on
that because i've taken his words
so so yeah thanks uh what that means
is we we've talked about where we
recognize
descendancy rights uh and that's an
issue that's still live with mahitahi
and we haven't resolved that
what what we're proposing is that the
development contribution policy
not be the vehicle through which that is
addressed
i.e the development concept
contributions would apply to each and
every
development uh irrespective of the
defendant descendants issue
however we are signaling that we
would like to bring back a separate
policy that deals specifically with the
descendancy issue so it would be
so for example and i just say this as an
example and
it may be that that a policy related to
descendancy may
say that uh the development
contributions that have been applied
under the development contributions
if a person or a property owner
shows descendancy then they work that
will entitle them to
x percent reduction in these or
all development contributions as a
as an alternate means of dealing with
that issue of descendancy rights which
we've yet to grapple with
and is still part with mahitahi
in the council
okay any further questions
council redmond you indicated prepared
to move eh so just
get hot on your secondary
moving the recommendation is that right
oh okay i'm sorry well can you sorry
pardon me
thank you mr mayor i'd like to move the
recommendation
i
d and e and insert
an amended b which would read
does not approve the draft development
contributions policy
for 2021 22 for consultation
as part of the 2021-22 long-term plan
special consultative procedure and
direct staff to undertake further work
in relation to district-wide
contributions and mr873 in particular
prior to consultation and report back to
council in january 2021
so we just be clear about that again
please
so so you're not moving you're not
including c so it's
a d e with a new b
let's give this to adrian to um
you adrian if you just we'll just get
that um clear first if we just hold for
a minute
question council
mr palmer aren't we required to consult
the draft development contributions
policy as part of our long-term plan
uh it needs to be included in our
long-term plan yes
so i'll just signal if if this meter
fails then i'll move the original motion
just to signal that intention
just wait for it to catch up
yes you are just get adrian to put it in
first and
then we'll be clear
not easily
so you've got that adrian so if we could
just read that out so it's a
um then d and e
does this does your does that is that a
b
as it does not approve so so can you
read the does not
does not adopt does it or is does not
approve
yes if you could read it that would be
great
can i help you because i think the
intent of what
council redmond is wanting to do is to
defer
consideration of the draft contributions
policy
until january
and ask us to come back and provide a
report on
district-wide contributions and i'm not
quite sure what that means and in
particular mrx73
prior to consultation so you're asking
really that this matter
be considered in january with the
further
advice about district wide
and mr873
is my understanding of yours mine's
another way of achieving that be to have
the measure lay on the table
and come to with that intent and come to
the
um ltp consideration with respect that
the intention is that district
development contributions be considered
for the whole district
and not consulted on part of the
district
excluding mr873
which would the way it is at the moment
be addressed later
my proposal was taking option two
on page two three four of diligent which
indicated the council could choose not
to approve the draft changes for
consultation
and direct the staff to undertake
further work prior to consultation
well the purpose of that we might be
debating it now so
yeah yeah um would we be not better off
to get that redrafted because
if if councillor ridman has to explain
that to us in that degree
then no one else is going to understand
what they are with respect
um what harm would it take
would it make to to lay this on the
table and for it to be considered as
part of the ltp
it's a procedural motion
but
correct i'm just asking the question all
right so you've put
councillor redmond has moved a motion
seconded by
council williams
how are we going to get it back to us in
january considering it's the first
december now well that no
no no we're debating the point so i've
signaled an intention that
um if this matter fails then i would be
prepared to move the original motion
so let the merits of this be discussed
now
and it's been moved in second and we'll
go there
all right councillor redmond
thank you mr mayor with with respect i
think the motion is quite clear
it seeks to have development
contributions for the whole
district consulted on in one hit
and not development contributions
excluding
mr873 consulted on
the date of january 2021 was when
there was a further report to come back
to council so
if that date's not feasible i'm i'm open
to
suggestions of extending that
my point is that
the whole district should be treated as
one and development contributions
we should be transparent and open and go
out and consult with what we're actually
doing
rather than deal with the easy part
first
and defer the harder part we need to
have that hard discussion at some stage
and i don't see
by putting it off that we're actually
achieving anything going forward
um so really that
that's it in a nutshell i'm not
suggesting what
the policy will be around the seas
but i just think the whole district
should be
in the consultation rather than
just dealing with part of the district
okay
further speakers i'll put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
contrary no
ceo could you conduct a division please
okay
so starting with uh gpm somewhere
williams
support
no
it's lost eight to three so
as i signaled earlier uh i moved to
um the original recommendation as
stated in the order paper and council
barnett
indicated she was second uh
just briefly speaking to that um look
i i i agree with the report it's it's
been well written so thank you
mike for that these matters are always
matters that we will discuss
as part of our long-term plan where
we are open and transparent as a council
it is there measures to do with what
council redmond raised
with they'll be the appropriate point in
which to have that conversation
and we will and whatever we decide to do
will certainly be open and transparent
it's always been my policy as a
councillor to be that way and
certainly no no change is mere in that
respect
we've got to be and we're audited by all
that new zealand and all
other bodies there's all our businesses
open
except when we're having px matters but
they often do fight
and need to find their way back into the
public arena at the appropriate time so
look
i'm comfortable with the recommendation
with the original recommendations so
councilwoman reserved
for the speakers
yes i i i've looked at this and this is
something that we do every single year
um in your in in every time that we
review the development
contributions policy it needs to go into
the long term plan
um and be part of the consultation for
everybody to have a look at
to make to throw darts in and to say
whether it's good bad or other
we had another submission today on
development contributions
so there there's high interest in this
policy we usually get quite a few
submissions on it each year
um so i'm really comfortable with it
going into the
long-term plan scp the
question of mr873 unfortunately i think
has come down to a matter of timing
it's not as far advanced as we would
have liked um
covert has delayed things and then we've
had changes in
the rooney we've had changes across the
board so i don't think there was any
intention
to delay the the discussion we need to
have
through mahitahi but i think it's
actually been a matter of timing
but that doesn't mean we shouldn't do
the all of the work that we've got
and just identify we've got an area that
needs more work
and i'm hoping that we will hear more um
in the new year
about that uh prior to releasing the
actual
draft document that sends out to the
public so
i don't think there's any advantage in
delaying
putting this through it actually is a
procedural issue
it needs to actually go into the
consultation and we will be receiving
further information
about mr873 which by law
is a very special part of the district
it is quite unique
in its legal framework and we do need to
consider it separately in many instances
so i'm fully supportive of the
recommendation
any further speakers council redmond
thank you mr mayor
i'm left in the position of either
supporting this motion or not
what i am concerned about is the
suggestion that existing development
contributions
may be written off it seems
in clause 4.4
i was of the view the development
contribution should apply over the whole
district including mr873
and not either exclude or have a
separate
regime there may be exceptions to this
policy
um but we spoke last month
that we're in a position that we don't
want to be giving money away
but it seems to me that we may have
indicated we're doing so
in returns in terms of mr873 with
a prior development where contributions
have not been paid
i would like to see one clear policy for
the district
and that these dc's are spread over the
whole
district so that's my
concern thank you further speakers
because yeah follow those same concerns
i
these um six houses i understood has
already been
negotiated a um development contribution
what's already owed and
well there has been a in the um papers a
figure that's
um they have actually thrust out at the
um
community that um is owed to the council
and um so i just
if i don't understand what's going on i
don't think the public can so
i'm a wee bit concerned i've asked the
chief executive question there's some
been some points raised i
appreciate some clarity jim as to the
status of the dc's
so in regards to the development
that has been undertaken that has been
subject to publicity
there have there are multiple elements
to that issue
some are a development contra so there's
development contributions
there are sometimes other charges that
are made
in terms of cost to be recovered through
which are not development contributions
but
but our contributions say to road
widening or something like that which is
not a development contribution matter so
important to separate development
contributions from other costs
associated
that we are seeking to recover as part
of the
of part of a normal development process
in terms of the development
contributions
they are parked at the moment and we've
agreed that they be parked until such
time as the council has determined its
policy
in respect of the issues
raised by
descendants of the original grant claim
for
mr873 at the current time
our current policy as is drafted
applies to every property in the
district
irrespective of whether they're a
grantee or not so
a proper a property in mr873 at the
moment has charged a development
contribution um irrespective of
the owners
uh descendancy rights
that come from the grant from the kemp's
deed
what the council has said through the
mahitahi committee is that it's prepared
to consider
the merits of the case proposed in
regards
to grantees
and for that to be considered by
mahitahi and
with a recommendation to council and
that's yet to happen as
councillor barnett said has been
deferred longer than we would like but
it's not in a place so
at that time there will be a policy that
the council will consider in the
meantime under this policy every
every development incurs a development
contribution like any other property
across the district
it is we are not seeking payment
while that the charge is being made at
this time we're not seeking payment
for those development contributions
until such time
as we have worked through the
the merits of that policy issue
hopefully things that's attempted to
clarify but i
appreciate it might not have thank you
that's fine so there is
there is an amount here of development
contributions which is how much
uh um i i don't have the exact i don't
have the
i don't have the numbers in front of me
but i imagine per
lot they are what per unit per dwelling
they're probably in the order of
130k across the six units or something
which
is what they which any irrespective of
descendancy they would have been charged
yeah and and these fees got parked at
the beginning of the process or
near the end of the process these places
being built um
that got it's been
i can't i can't tell you
through their build process when they've
got parked we certainly
it's been raised as an issue by them
uh by them by um representatives of
naitu area it's been raised as an issue
for quite some time
and flows on from the apology we gave in
we had intended to have dealt with this
probably six or 12 months ago but
for a variety of reasons it hasn't got
to that stage
therefore we are honoring our
undertaking to
not seek payment of those until the
matter is
resolved
first questions further speakers
counselor at concert thank you mr man i
hope you do
support the uh this this motion as it
sits
here on the table i see this very much
and very appropriate that we had a
deputation today um from
the very same situation what did we do
with that we can give the gentleman an
answer
we haven't given them an answer and
beforehand we've parked it
for it to come back to council with the
appropriate report
so that we can get the appropriate
advice to make sure we make the
appropriate decision
working through mahitahi and working
with
with the descendants we are doing
exactly
the same thing apart from one thing they
are our partners
treaty partners and this is the area of
there's a special area it has different
rules in it and it
and it will have further different rules
in it as we negotiate through
a very tricky street to get to i suppose
it'll never be an end but
a considered end of where we need to be
this isn't actually going to give
a special treatment as such it is giving
the right amount of consultation
listening and learning that we need to
have
to navigate the very issue that we're
just talking about
and again i reiterate with a non-treaty
partner
we just did that today in a deputation
by asking for a report
it is no different in that respect so
any further speakers
well then write a reply i'm just going
to say that
with good reflections thank you to the
ceo for his clarity but can i just say
that we're not ready
to give any report back at this point
because we haven't had
a final conversation where we've reached
a point
that we can recommend back to the
council from mahitahi
and i just want to re-emphasize that
it's about just
i don't want to rush this it's been a
matter
and it's quite delicate and those who
counselors who've sat in
that that know it's delicate we've as as
as members representing the council
we've given no
undertaking that will be council's
position and have made it very clear
that will be a matter for council to
consider uh ultimately
and and that's really where it is we're
having an open conversation about it
and i'm hoping that as soon as we're in
the position to bring that back to
council we will do so
it's been very difficult to get times
together because i have covert
and and b we were recently to have a
meeting but there was a a measure at the
mariah which prevented that
we've got a conversation in the next
coming i think it's next week
and we will schedule further in the new
year but
when we've got a position to bring
forward we will do so
there's nothing to but i don't think we
should hold the
development our draft development
contributions policy up because of that
because it will be considered with the
council and it will be council's
decision ultimately if we take a
position or not on that
okay so um with that i'm going to put
the councilwood
well i've just put i've just spoken so
um i've just given the right of reply so
um anyway i'll allow it
um what would you like if you'd like to
say something i don't want to shut the
conversation there altogether
well you know the little bit that i do
know about it is that what we're saying
is that we want to approve a draft
development
um contributions policy for consultation
without without it being a district-wide
one so
because we're saying that we're going to
go we're going to consider
um mr 873 separately and come to council
anyway so
i think that councillor um
redmond's um viewpoint
that let's do a district-wide and and
delay things for consultation is quite
relevant
okay that's just my opinion okay i'm
going to put the recommendation now all
those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried
sorry what was that i didn't hear what
you said counseling
okay all right it's hard to clear that
carried
all right does anyone want their votes
recorded
it's just councillor williams and
council award
all right we now come to 9.6 pages
282-288
new tsunami modeling i think nick's
presenting on behalf of brennan who's
not able to be with us today
and and matt yep thank you thank you mr
mayor yes thank you
apologies from brennan but he's actually
home with flu-like symptoms
yes no he's off for a covert test but i
think that'll be
really unlikely
the mana of brennan he needs two
controllers to present his report
i think please if we could turn to page
288 that's the one with the
two maps on there and that's probably
best just to speak quickly around this
report
on 288 the left-hand map is our
current evacuation zones for our current
tsunami modelling now this modeling was
done
probably 10 years ago prior to putting
in the tsunami siren system
and you'll see the little red areas
around the beach settlements
and they're quite distinct little blocks
they're not contiguous
last year environment canterbury ng
nested updated modelling and we saw some
of that when it just touched on
waimakariri river mouth
earlier this year and then they've gone
away and done the balance of banks
peninsula
and northern pegasus bay and that
modelling now
has led to the map on the right which is
uh proposed
new evacuation zones maybe just pause
for that just to get distracted
with what you're saying
just getting some high-tech plug-in
system
sorry just for a moment apologizing
okay thanks nick thanks just the map on
the right
has three colors it has the red orange
and yellow
the red one is basically for any tsunami
alert that
um nema might put out and that's just
the beach area and that's basically
you know go get out of there the orange
one
is for the near or medium sources and
armies this is the higarangi kumadik
trench
ones where we have about 90 minutes
and the yellow ones are for the distant
south american ones now this model talks
about a very large
distant south american one we're talking
about 9.5
type magnitude so it's pretty big and
to give you an idea the yellow one is
around a two and a half thousand
year return period and the orange one
is about a 500 year return period so
we're talking long
time scales here now
brennan's met with not only the
ecan scientists but also our roading
unit the police the fire service and
that to try to get
some sort of simple evacuation zone
that can be relatively quickly got
together
by a limited number of people should the
balloon go up um bearing in mind
for the orange area we we have possibly
90 minutes to get something in place
so fundamentally we shouldn't ignore the
warning the fundamental one
long strong get gone sort of thing so
bearing in mind that we're going to
probably have restricted or limited
resources because
tsunami will be affecting the entire
coastline of
that side of the country the police have
advised that they would like the minimum
number of intersections to
put cordons on if you like to stop
people going back into the zone
so you'll see that the the zone areas
are quite large they do
by and large cover the modeled
inundation area
but they've also just been modeled to
road or known
boundaries where we can actually put
cordons on
the report asks for the council to
endorse these zones they're
essentially there for information but
the second part of the report
is about a consultation exercise where
we'll need to do next year now this
report is essentially silent on that
consultation exercise
we haven't turned our mind fully to what
that is we've turned it mindful
enough to know that um
even though we want to go and talk to
the community on tsunamis the community
may actually want to talk about a whole
lot of other hazards
and that was touched on a couple of
reports ago with simon
with sea level rise and climate change
so we've got to have a think about that
and one of the recommendations is to
come back to the council
with a better communication strategy
about that for next year
thank you mr man thank you did you want
anything
i think just in the recommendation see
did say
endorses it we probably think it's
probably better notes
as a word at the moment rather than
endorses
me something we can think of
um count the jewish question sorry
question
uh right hold on ward
duty blacky okay
councillor atkinson thank you
nick i'm just wondering why
this is not an information report
and that there's not something it's not
we receive and wait for the information
on the consultation
on what that's going to be because this
is going to go out
and there's going to be a zone in here
we're going to scare the hell out of
everybody
without even know what we're going to
talk about would it not be better
and i'm looking for some advice here to
lay this on the table until we have
a communications plan to the public to
actually
do something with this i
certainly appreciate your point and it's
it's a
dilemma we talked through when we were
given this information
um relatively late in the period our
problem is
that christchurch city has already gone
out with us and
her annuities if they haven't gone out
with it they're going out with it
shortly now
admittedly both those councils are doing
what they call a soft launch of it
so it's pretty quiet but i think you've
raised a valid point
in terms of is it the horse or the cat
if you like
first and um the information is already
going to be out there
with our cousin council so
we've kind of got to put it out there
ourselves but it's how we actually
consult the community as
a particular difficulty because the
world
looking at this report i'm asking you
about i would challenge the validity of
this report
i see that that so your question is my
question is
how do they get the orange bits there
without
um even with any of them not including
brooklyn's lagoon
because i do happen to know that
brooklyn's lagoon is impacted on a
on a tsunami yes and you're absolutely
right
it is impacted on all of these scenarios
it's just that it's in christchurch city
and won't be mapped on our maps but
otherwise it looks very much like this
council award you're quite right
okay uh councillor duty thank you
just a query please with the the red
going right
up the waimakariri
so um what do you what is that
telling us that suddenly the rip is
going to be
inundated with sea water what
i i think what it's telling us is within
the stock banks there
we will see a title search right
and we may see several title searches
might not be just one way no
no thank you because this is probably
very
but that would be very important for the
residents that live around that area
right so yeah okay council blicky
nick you happen to know all this
modeling what what
level i i may have missed this somewhere
and
back down the line what level of tsunami
they talk
about for this modeling because i mean
um you know one meter one meter one
won't get past the sand hills 2.5
our stock banks at kaiapoi and the
waimak will contain that
a 10 we're all dead you know what what
do they model it on
yes um that i can i can speak for the
south american one it's um
a magnitude 9.5 i think so it's you know
that in itself is a as a reimbursement
yes yes thanks thanks matt three
three to five meters it may even be more
than that for those big ones
i think that there's an amalgamation of
about 27 different models and some of
them are three and some of them are five
so
that what they do then is they smash
those all together and come up with
the key model for for both but it yeah
it is really an amalgamation of a whole
lot of different scenarios
uh kel's written oh thank you
and that now that we have this
information what are
our obligations um do we put it in limbs
or
yes we we already what do we do with it
yes thank you councillor edmund we do
have some wording in limbs already
i think we need to just look at that in
the light of this new modeling here
just to see that the words actually
still reflect what this model is telling
us
further further questions
moved uh uh sorry council barnett you
happy with the sea with notes
now it's up to you as moving it i was
suggesting to leaving be as endorsers
it's up to you
okay okay seconded counts the redmond
council this information has been out
since or
started to come out about november 2019
and so we have a duty of care to put it
out to our public
it's been unfortunate we haven't been
able to have a good conversation but
there's been a lot of other things
happening this year
um this is these are big events and they
only happen
with with little regularity however
we we do have a duty of care that we
have to take note of them
and whether the modelling is right or
wrong or whether it's the best
information we have at the moment
it's become very very clear that the
evacuation zones we have in place
are not going to suffice going into the
future and whether it's one side of a
road or not or not whether you get your
feet wet or whether it's up to your neck
that's going to be it's going to be
subjective no matter what sort of
emergency we have
we can't predict everything but i think
it's really important that we've got
this out
in our public so people can come and ask
questions and people can approach our
civil defence team any time
to ask questions or our planning unit um
this is a this is a guide this is to
help us get it right for our community
and longer term we'll have to put some
plans in place but now i think it's
appropriate just to note
the information has been received and
next year we will be discussing
more fully how we talk to people about
it more widely to make them aware
and what they can do to help themselves
because this is often just about what
the community has to do to help
themselves
in that 90 minutes for the short range
ones to actually make sure they can
keep as many people safe as possible so
i welcome that the fact that this is now
on the table
and i welcome the fact that anyone can
now ask questions about it
from our particularly from the coastal
and river areas of our district
thank you uh secondary council redmond
thank you mr mayor um christchurch city
received their modeling earlier in the
year
and from what nick had said
are only shortly going out with their
consultation
i'm not sure when hironui received their
information but i'm assuming it's around
the same time as us
i think it's important we get our
response right
rather than rush it because it is quite
significant and there will be
a number of decisions such as whether we
extend the siren
system or how we manage these particular
zones
whether there is one zone or whether we
have the three different zones so
that's something we'll need to discuss
in the new year so
i'm pleased that we finally have this
information
um it
the time period sort of makes you wonder
what level of risk
people are going to face um
i guess it is unlikely but it still
could happen so
um i think this is really just the first
step
because yeah two and a half thousand
year return period
come on what are we trying to protect
people from here get out of their damn
backyards
this is ridiculous two and a half
thousand year
return period what's next two and a half
thousand year return period for a fire
hmm that'd be quite good we should
consult and protect people against there
come on really
joke further speakers
council duty just looking at this
i'm just decided that we're damned we're
doomed
damned if we're doomed um yeah no
because uh you need water wings down
there and up and up in the
uh higher reach you probably need a hard
hat so
it's going to hit somewhere along the
line isn't it
any further speakers look i think it's
important that we do
share the information that we have we
have a duty to do that
how we do that is the question that we
need to think about carefully
and and i think nick it's just a matter
for you and the team to reflect on
particularly when we're about to go out
with district plan long-term plan
there's a lot of engagement about to go
out there in a bit of overload so it's
about
just reflecting on that timing
of when that goes out but when we have
this information we and their other
partner councils
are about to share we do need to to make
sure that that information is available
we have a duty to do so i don't want to
scare the horses
the oxford horse in particular um pardon
wendy
but it is it is just important that we
do
make sure that information is available
and it's just
it's a fact it's a factor in
consideration
look we have this information we do have
a responsibility to share it we're not
saying don't build here don't do this
we're just saying
if this happens if if a happens then do
b
and and forewarned is forearmed and and
if
if the two and a half thousand year
event happens during our lifetime
and people know that we knew and we
didn't tell them then there will be hell
to pay so i don't really see any harm
whatsoever in us
communicating this information and not
scaring the horses or horse
as it were and
you know i mean we're not telling people
they can't do things we're just saying
hey be aware of this
and if this actually happens then
do this so i'm happy to support it
sorry i'm just doing a punch for tonight
we've got the af8
earthquake presentation in oxford
just very quickly this is happening all
over new zealand this is not peculiar to
us
okay so this is this is all councils are
facing this
um it's important we do it now because
of budget we have to be very very
careful if we're not
if we look at our emergency management
budgets um and make sure that we've got
this right for going forward we've got
the duty of care there um yes
absolutely there's a level of risk but
this is about being prepared it's not
necessarily about the council doing it
and yes it could could be two and a half
thousand years it could be next week
um
thank you miss mia um this is the time
of year where we just take
the opportunity to review our interest
register
which we have on our website constantly
um i've already received one update in
recent days
and so i'm asking for
either any amendments at this time or
notification and say the next 24 hours
for the documentation can be updated and
placed on our website
your choice um email is
absolutely fine thank you
sorry adrian first is good streets it's
david and rob
thank you after mr mayor
this report is effectively a process
report which wraps up a
decision of the council some years ago
in relation to the
rearrangement of the traffic flow behind
the new world around europe
what we need to do is just finally stop
the service lane which is actually legal
road
and then we can finalize the transaction
and then move forward and then it's
complete
okay so that's your report complete yes
any questions or papers because the
meetings
um so this is the service lane at the
back of new world right
okay so um i know well a couple
questions i guess i know there's a
parking
area at the back of lamb house so how
will they access that parking area
will the stoppage affect their access
no no at all because what what we see
now is what the final product is
so that the um the stopping the the
service line is actually
there's effectively in behind the fence
line where the with the new world have
their activity going on with the
unload goods so that's that's already
actually happened physically
okay um so i just want to make sure i
understand so we're not talking about
stopping the road
that goes through there okay because
yeah i know that there are some
businesses that depend on that so
um that's where thank you for clarifying
that thank you
okay uh council williams
i probably am wrong but i thought the
original was cost neutral to the council
this deal why is there a hundred
thousand dollars now unbudgeted when
originally was put as a cost neutral
scenario originally
i'm not quite sure where the hundred
thousand dollars comes from as far as
i'm aware that it's cost neutral
i think you're looking at the old report
which was dated in 2016 councilor
williams
yeah okay um council ward i'm just
trying to find it all here but
um having read it um as part of this
is there an option to do for 84 000
to do relocate before it gets finalized
relocate the the underground surfaces is
that part of
of this consideration yeah i can talk to
that um
that was considered right earlier on in
the project
when it was being worked through in
terms of options uh
um in my recollection uh is that there
was a significant amount of life left in
the services
and so the cost of relocating it at that
point in time
was not considered to be cost effective
so you're writing off
a substantial length of life of those
underground services at that point
um so they're my understanding is that
there's provision for
good access and it's been worked through
with our
three waters team um for any maintenance
and
and ongoing upkeep
further questions some prepare to move
councillor atkinson seconded by council
award council records if you wish to
speak
councilwood any further speakers
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear it carried thank you
dave and rob we now come to uh 1.1
sorry not 1.2 it's 9.9
pc 30 so trevor thank you
good afternoon thank you for your time
uh just to be brief this is a report
that
recommends making a submission on pc30
which is a ravenswood
plan change at northwood end uh you
received a report on this in october
from staff
which was a report around accepting the
plan change for public notification
which has occurred
and it also signaled the option to put
in a submission should accounts push to
do so
so this report attaches a draft
submission at the stage for council to
consider
to lodge on that plan change submissions
close on the 4th of december
and just to reiterate this is a
submission from council
and that's different from the staff
offices report which will also be put
forward as part of the plan change
process
so there are four recommendations in
front of you and i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you thanks thanks trevor any
questions of members
okay um some were appeared to move the
recommendation
moved by accounts about it i was second
up because
both of us were involved in that so uh
council about it
we did have to try and seek to balance
this um
submission because obviously we're we're
looking at
there is a commercial area in in the
ravenswood subdivision
um as part of northwood end and it did
seem to have the land available to be
the clear kac
in that area so we we looked at that
quite clear carefully however the scale
was
seen as very difficult to manage because
we don't actually accept the economic
report it had
a lot of holes in it and we're hoping
that what will happen is the officers
report will actually have a look at the
um the submission and the
economic report and actually identify
that the markets that were
were rather overstated so our submission
is
fairly neutral but it's still saying
that we reject uh the scale of the
submission
of the subdivision that they would like
to do and the change of
zoning so i think it's it's a nice
middle ground however
it'll be interesting to see what other
submissions are reached from other
people because i
understand there's quite a lot of
interest in the community
thank you and sorry you've got a
question question counselor
on your head
um can we circulate to all boards
because this is actually a district
issue
sorry i'm here to say before yes yep no
i'm
you happy as beaver council ballot yep
uh i am the second of the surf weekend
just to
mean that um look i'm supportive of the
um submission so just to endorse the
comments made by councillor barna
thank the staff for the work well the
support
to an advice that was provided
the scale of development is certainly a
concern to a large number of people i've
had a lot of phone calls
about it certainly since last week of
people concerned about the size of scale
i think our submission deals with that
where it talks about the gross floor
area
uh from what was originally proposed it
was 34 000
to to up to 14 000 so it gives that
opportunity for our staff
to be involved in a conversation about
how that is managed
and ultimately it'll be a matter that's
up to the commissioner to consider
and those that hear this particular
matter
it'll be appropriate through that course
that that matter is tested and
ultimately they'll make a call and
recommendation back so
comfortable with that process but i
think it's appropriate given the
concerns that are being raised that
we certainly do test that can i just say
i think raven on
ravenswood are a very good developer
council has a very good relationship
with them as we do with
all our developers in our district but
they're just putting forward options
where they see an opportunity and good
good luck to them that's that's the
process that
we follow through through that and they
had every right in which to put this
forward
the council also has a right to protect
its main tech to consider its main town
centres and the effect that it may have
on that and what would be appropriate at
that level
and we've given some reflection on that
and as i said before that'll be up to
the commissioner in which to make a call
in that respect based on all the
information put forward
councillor atkinson then followed by
councillor ward thank you mr mayor
well while i think the staff and
everybody's done the best they can with
this i do i agree with
14 000 square metres no i don't it's
twice as much as should be there and i
realize it's been cut in half as a
suggestion
to start with so it's up to you yes um
will this go through 86 percent of
resource consents go through so will it
go through you said well
all of the numbers and the kaiakoi town
centre and the ranger a town centre plan
involved in this 14 000 square meters
and now we're going to add 14 000 square
meters not through any fault of our own
through a developer
we can call the developer responsible if
we like
but i'm not quite sure that responsible
is the word um when you're looking at
adding
retail when these other people who
actually do travel
to rangiora and kaikou and i know the
argument
that will come that they will say we
want to shop in our own backyard and
we don't want to drive our car well
sorry
but this these towns not only
historically but
future for us in in this district has
always been the key activity centres of
colorado europe
and i actually think that this is over
irresponsible
um in the fact that they that they're
going to
create what they want to create here
it's not so much
about the actual square footage it's
about what they want to create there
you will we have people that come to
rangora all the time from
amberly from places there that will go
and into the if if people don't think
this will affect our retailers
it will i know of three submissions that
will be hitting
this and the commissioner will have to
decipher them
the reality is that 99 of these go
through
you know and and i just think that it's
actually irresponsible of a developer to
this level um on the edge of a town
when they know that it actually will rip
the business out of
the two major centres that are in our
district
councilwood this probably is a little
bit irrelevant but um
is there an issue with the road that
is connecting through through ravenswood
town to the
no there's no in terms of the uh road
that will connect frank euro would end
with a state highway there's no
issue with that there was a bit of an
issue with some laying of some ash felt
within a subdivision area that got
ripped up and
replaced but there's no actual
concern about the through road
okay for the speakers right for applying
oh sorry
councillor thank you mr mayor
um this plan change from what i can
detect seems to have some local support
around wood end and pegasus
they've been looking for a commercial
centre to replace the one that never
eventuated at pegasus
i've i was quite surprised when i saw in
the newspaper it was going to be the
third main
centre in waimakariri
which indicated to me it was the biggest
scale that i first
anticipated i think there will be
effects
in the district but perhaps one of the
main effects may be
north christchurch especially with the
new motorway and corridors and so on
locals may tend to shop locally and by
locals i mean pegasus
woodend and ravenswood residents
the main concern that i've picked up is
how
people are going to cross state highway
one on
foot or bicycle to get to the shopping
areas
and i'm referring to people from pegasus
primarily
so that's not part of our submission and
it may be
too late um to include it but that does
seem to be the main concern
i've encountered
thank you any further speakers write
reply accounts about it
um just very quickly i think it's really
really important to note that the woody
and pegasus population once it's fully
developed will be as large as kaiapoi
so therefore there was always intended
in our policy statements
to have a kac in the woody and pegasus
area and that's
reflected in all the documents that
we've put through from the draft board
william figures strategy through to our
district development plan
and so therefore we are actually
following the regional policy statement
with that as well
um i think what we'll we'll see a
different type of development
in the ravenswood subdivision i call it
the ravenswood commercial area because i
think that's what we really should refer
to it as
um right ringer and kaipoy have
developed
um organically so they've started with
small and they're built and they're
built and they're built
this is a greenfield's development it
has scale to do different
things that can't be done in the ranging
cbd
and there are a lot of retailers in um
in christchurch who are now eyeing up
our district particularly with motorway
and saying they might want to come here
so what that actually does is it then
prevents
leakage into christchurch that's the
argument that the developers are always
going to give you
and i totally i totally accept that but
there's also
a lot of people out here who would like
to see some of those retailers
in our district and we don't have the
land in the middle of the
cbd's so therefore there are some
benefits they already have bp
they already have a supermarket it's
already happening they've already got
mcdonald's
and local people will shop local so
woody and pegasus people
will probably shop and that's in that
supermarket
um in that area however i think it can
actually be this
i remember when the warehouse came to
grand euro everyone was terrified that
all of the retail would disappear
it didn't it attracted people as a
destination it's
quite possible um that having a kac and
woody and pegasus will attract people
off state highway 1 into our district
and we can attract them further on from
here so i actually
i don't think it's all bad but i do
agree the scale
was far too large um and in the current
economic climate it's going to be very
very hard to justify
so i'm sure any commissioner with the
salt will look at that and look at that
economic report
and say actually guys there's no way
that you can actually do that but i
agree
finishing a bit of retail out of north
christchurch
the fact that ranger and kaiapoi are
quite specialists and they have
different type of shopping to what
ravenswood is probably going to offer
i don't think we're actually facing a
lot of risk as much as we're facing a
lot of opportunity
okay i'll put the thank you council
about i put the recommendation all those
in favor please say aye
contrary clear that carried
right so
just um so item 10 we've got no matters
referred
from committees and community boards in
this
part of the agenda um health and safety
11.1
uh mr mr palmer thanks a
report there taken as read since that
report there's probably been there has
been one
uh event that's probably worth noting
that will come in next week next week's
or next month's uh summary and that was
a
a crash um on south brook road
of one of our uh staff in a council car
uh wrote the car off and uh the
staff member head was okay although
shaken up and bruised
but is now back at work so um that will
come through
um wasn't necessarily not their fault
sorry um yeah so uh that that's just
um uh by way of update but there is
there are no other matters
needing to be brought to your attention
thank you thank you any questions of mr
palmer
council williams first and then i've
noticing you're
moving yes i noticed another one backing
in
uh a staff relying on cameras more often
with the sun and the camera surely
i noticed in the top on the um driver
training
i've been told to not just look into
cameras
it's mirrors until you head around it's
not the first time this is brought up
but
yeah and i i get annoyed when you get
people blaming your camera
they're lazy um well i i suspect i
suspect
uh the staff member concerned has used
the camera
and because of that factor
didn't do those other things which
you've suggested and
probably they should have um and
your comment is noted okay
um so any further questions counselor
becky's indicating he's prepared to move
i'll repeat the second off oh
seconded counselor atkinson do you wish
to speak to it
let's reconcile any further speakers
i'll put the
recommendation always in favor aye
contrary to clear that carried
we have um committee minutes for
information 12.1
and 12.2 moved by
so moved by council records and seconded
by council of duty
any discussion all those in favor aye
contrary to clear that carried we also
have the minutes as listed there from
the community boards uh there's
there's someone here to move moved to
council duty sync into the council of
barnet
any discussion all those in favor aye
contrary to care that declare that
carrots are account so williams can you
turn your
your lights on so um
no reports for information no
correspondence
you can come to my diary pages 367-369
any questions i'm not going to say
anything too much i speak to it any
questions
all right so someone prepared to move
moved by councillor blacky's second
about council board any
uh do you wish to speak okay i'll put
the recommendation
all those in favor aye contrary to clear
that carried
um come to council portfolio updates
uh ewe relationships first um just to
advise we've got a runa meeting coming
up
i think that's the 16th of december and
mahita he's
next week on the 8th so
two meetings coming up
also on saturday there's a
celebration for day marahar at
tuahue to celebrate her becoming a dame
so we
account the councillor concern myself
and the chief executive
been officially invited to their honesty
today so we'll be representing the
council there
that's at 11 o'clock and we'll be making
a dash
post-poet-free hopefully to get to the
christmas parade and kaiboy but
might be leaving germany to represent us
so
what's that sorry oh look i'll come to
that at the end
yeah okay everyone so um that's and this
is there any questions
of me with eerie relationships
okay so canterbury water management
strategy council stuart
uh thank you um nothing
um that well it is i guess significant
um
the this is the last week of the pc
seven hearings and they finish on
um on friday um
and i attended on monday to hear
um naitahi and my
[Music]
and i quote they have called for
dramatic
and immediate change
in how farming is managed here they want
restoration of
[Music]
the waterways there was a discussion to
start with about
the scope of the plane change
in the light of um the lodging of the
uh claim from rangatiratanga over
waterways
um and the decision was that it
it doesn't impact on on what's being
heard
although of course you realize um
and it was started off when the hearings
began
that the nps british order 2020 will be
given legal effect too
uh under um under this plan
change um tomorrow is um
oh there was quite a it's quite an
interesting read
um they're all online and they're all
on youtube so uh it's interesting to
just review what's going on tomorrow is
federated farmers which i'm
planning to get to and um on
friday um they'll be
[Music]
yes just the wind up of um some
individual farmers
now putting their case um i i'd be
interested to know what your time frame
is for your
decision making do we get do we have any
all the recommendations that will come
from the planet or what time
during the year do we expect in
the in the fullness of time the fullness
of time
marvelous excellent excellence the only
other
thing and um really that's um
that's the la uh there's another water
zone meeting
um on monday and that will be the last
one for the year
um develop because i've got the
biodiversity portfolio and i don't
actually
sit on officially the community
recreation committee i'll report a bit
of biodiversity in here because it is
it is um it is part and parcel of the
water management strategy but
the working group biodiversity working
group which has fallen out of the water
zone
committee continues to progress
a waimakariri biodiversity trust
which and at the moment it's still in
um talking around engaging interest
um potential trustees it's it's
following potentially the model um in
selwyn
of tiara kakariki and
as i indicated before they came to speak
to the
working group so i think there is
probably
um interest in a standalone
district-wide waimakuri biodiversity
trust
is um many other council areas
have that we are deficient in that we we
have
some trusts that that do particular
patches but
nothing that is district district-wide
and the model in selwyn um addresses
um public and private land it is funded
um with uh seed funding from the um
southwind district council and has been
going for a decade
so um i i would say that there would be
[Music]
we have um interest in furthering that
here and it may be
that there is an application to the ltp
for something
um welcome any questions thanks
counselors you have any questions
all right just before i come to um
international relationships it was
remiss of me not to mention earlier
um that i found out this morning via
adrian that freddie the clerk
sadly um has been diagnosed with covert
he's still here
um but um his whole family have in fact
covered i think it may have been
introduced by his son but
to the family but we just i guess i just
like to say on put on our minutes
the record that we acknowledge this but
by the thinking of him at this time
because clearly it's a very troubling
issue and i um
we've seen a copy of the segment of our
minutes to reflect
our thoughts and i'll send freddie an
email later
today passing it on
um international relationships uh deeply
near
we should just reach out that we we have
been
approached by friends from wuhan
who would like a social engagement at
some particular point so
it will be the new year so
not living in wuhan based in
christchurch
but um we haven't made it here
yes okay um all right 17.4
council becky i got very little to
report to mr mayor um
only two things the the community hub in
courtney drive
the pre-consultation notice has gone out
to all the adjacent
residents about 67 maybe 70
that are going to be affected with a
noise or visual
range of the proposed hub just to get
their
their feedback before michelle starts
getting into
into too far into develop into
development
and the changing rooms for absolutely
finished in cass street
with a car park to die for the best car
park in the district
and no one's complained about it not
that um that i went with green space
staff and
and did an inspection the other day and
it's it's
extremely extremely good facility it's
it's open in the
row of public toilets open to the public
on the outside of the building
they're up in fact
thank you any questions of council
blacky council atkinson
you just
on the bmx track that those toilets are
open because that seems to be the
biggest
question down there of where the
facilities are so i'm not sure but
you're only 60 yards away in a straight
line it's very obvious
right um
sorry all right
any other questions of counselor becky
okay we come to 17.5 climate change and
sustainability council meetings
try to make that brief um yeah so they
we rather on the 11th of the 11th we had
a
climate on the internal staff climate
change coordination group
met to share info across the council on
um
matters of you know climate change
adaptation and mitigation efforts
um and then also during november
the audit new zealand long-term plan
self-assessment questions were compiled
and they included questions on what
assumptions the council would make in
relation to the impacts of climate
change
some of those questions were included
also an inquiry about how council
planned to reflect its climate change
emergency declaration in the long-term
plan consultation document which of
course is not relevant for us because we
haven't done that
but as you're all aware last week the
government
has declared that they are heading
towards declaring
a climate emergency for all of new
zealand so that just gives you an idea
where that's headed
um the results of the consultation on
the draft climate change policy you've
heard about today so
move on um last week was interesting for
those of you that made it to the the
greater christchurch 2050 stakeholder
workshops they had um
over over three days you know you're all
aware of what what they did but um it
was rather interesting because the
stakeholders that they had were
from really diverse areas like i
actually sat next to
a friend of mine from a hoka who's
a professional board member basically
quite high up in accounting circles and
whatnot so i know he was clever but then
i sat across from my
um old university economics lecturer
and i went wow okay so they really
really have cast the net far but
there was just a really diverse group of
people in the one that i was able to
attend
and everybody in that room regardless of
where they came from
um was was very highly engaged with the
idea of
climate change and and sustainability
and in moving
um greater christchurch in that
direction
for our future so it's interesting to
see that you know that that right across
our communities is um something that is
being
discussed you know commonplace so it is
part of the
the vernacular these days i think um
and then after that i attended the first
ccc coastal hazards working group as the
observer as you guys remember we were
discussing
and basically it's early days for them
they are discussing consultation options
and adaptation options
and they're having a community
information center on the 9th of
december
so that's pretty much where they're at
with that and they
are planning on also having staff to the
next ones as well so simon
has been invited and i think jared would
i think they must have yeah some other
staff anyway so um and
the climate sorry the
staff sustainability champions met last
week as well
um they run off their feet really
like everybody else so i'll leave that
at that
and the canterbury regional climate
change working group
is scheduled to meet on the 9th of
december and that will be the
first meeting chaired by the new ecan
chief scientist tim dr tim davey
and that's it for me any questions any
questions
counselor williams just one um being
raised in this country just
today can they give you a definition of
what an emergency is
in climate change emergency next con
could you ask that question please
sure
you just want me to ask the question yep
or answer the question
look i i just think as far as you know
them talking about emergency is the fact
that we we've pushed the can down the
road
probably since we're all kids and now
they're going you know what don't kick
the can anymore pick the can up and do
something with it so that's that's my
interpretation but
i'll ask
okay right thank you uh
thanks council meetings um so i have no
questions
no urgent general business um
um i'll move now that we uh matters to
be considered with the public excluded
there's a recommendation so
move to that recommendation some are
prepared to move moved by council
atkinson seconded
council award um
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye contrary to clear that carrots
when they're in public excluded